bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous si
vous nous rejoignez à l'instant sur les
chaînes parlementaires bienvenus
bienvenue dans cette grande soirée
électorale consacré évidemment aux
résultats du second tour de notre
élection présidentielle ce résultat le
voilà ce soir emmanuel macron a été
réélu pour cinq ans à la tête de la
france avec 58,2 % des voix pour contre
marine le pen
41,8 % des suffrages une victoire donc
assez nette mais c'est néanmoins le plus
gros score réalisé par le rassemblement
national à cette élection nous allons
évidemment avoir l'occasion d'en
débattre avec nos invités politiques ici
même en plateau puis avec nos experts
dans cette soirée ils sont là pour nous
expliquer le choix des français pour se
projeter dans ce nouveau quinquennat on
a vu dans les prises de parole les
déclarations notamment de jean luc
mélenchon de marine le pen ou d'eric
zemmour un climat peut-être jamais vu
dans l'histoire de notre vème république
au soir d'une victoire au au second tour
à voir comment le rapport de force peut
se traduire aux prochaines législatives
alors pour vous faire vivre cette soirée
voici notre dispositif elsa mondain
gaven se trouve aux côtés des partisans
d' emmanuel macron au champ de mars et
puis tam tran huy est aussi avec les
équipes de marine le pen au pavillon
d'ermenonville alors on peut voir un
autre chiffre qui est celui de
l'abstention cette élection a été
marquée par une très forte abstention
28,2 % des français ne se sont pas
rendus aux urnes voilà pour l'estimation
de l'abstention de nos partenaires ipsos
sopra et steria pour les chaînes
parlementaires france 2 et france inter
on va parler de tout cela évidemment
avec nos invités agnès pannier-runacher
bonsoir soit vous êtes ministre délégué
chargé de l'industrie bienvenus on
attend philippe ballard je vous le
signale le porte parole du rassemblement
national et en attendant pierre latry
chef du groupe cdu sauce et restez vous
pourrez nous éclairer sur certains
certaines informations du sondage dont
on parle depuis le début de cette soirée
danièle obono merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député la france insoumise
de paris et gérard longuet bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur républicain de la meuse et
ancien ministre a nié ce panier une
hache et je commence avec vous il ya une
victoire nette je le disais ce soir
d'emmanuel macron avec 58,2 % des voix
pour autant est-ce que c'est un vote
d'adhésion pour le candidat sortant
alors d'abord je veux dire que je suis
très heureuse très heureuse de la
confiance que nous font 58% des français
c'est un président qui est plutôt bien
élu par rapport aux élections la vème
république un en termes de pourcentages
d'inscrits et je crois que dans ce
moment c'est probablement le meilleur
projet pour les français qu'il s'agisse
du volet écologie du volet pouvoir
d'achat et de nous deux autres projets
mais ça veut dire que vous ne la sentais
pas amendée votre projet étant donné les
oppositions très forte qui se sont
exprimés ce soir à la fois dans la
bouche marine le pen et dans celle de
jean-luc mélenchon je crois que les
préoccupations qui ont manifesté les
français l ont été très clair je pense
qu'on partage la préoccupation de
l'écologie je pense qu'on partage là que
la préoccupation du pouvoir d'achat sur
la préoccupation de l'écologie un
certain nombre de propositions
formulées par jean luc mélenchon se
pense la fin par exemple des plastiques
à usage unique ça a déjà été fait par le
président de la république et vous voyez
qu'on est bien sur la même ligne sur
certains sujets on ne naît pas sur
l'énergie donc il ya des choses dont on
peut débattre il ya des choses sur
lequel on n'est pas d'accord à nous de
convaincre demain les français sur le
sujet et on le fera en responsabilité le
président de la république l'a dit très
clairement son sujet et de prendre en
compte ce qui a été dit par les français
moi j'ai été beaucoup sur le territoire
dans le bassin minier etc on entend
cette colère on l'entend ses demandes et
mais vous avancer les choses et associer
notre programme qui s'appliquera non je
vous ai dit ce soir le programme que
nous proposons répond en partie à ses
besoins et nous sommes prêts en
concertation avec les français avec les
clans intermédiaire à r en sorte de
répondre à ces quatre objectifs les
quatre objectifs de notre projet c'est
pouvoir d'achat écologie école santé
alors né reviendra évidemment je
voudrais je voudrais résidents merci
donner la parole à danièle obono tout de
suite parce que vous dites président
bien élu pour jean luc mélenchon celle
inverse il je le cite un dans son
discours tout à l'heure le président le
plus mal élu des présidents de la vème
république
qu'est ce qui lui fait dire ça vous
faire dire ça et à quel point vous êtes
dans une opposition totalement frontale
c'est le sentiment qui a été donné dans
le discours de jean luc mélenchon il n'y
a même pas eu on évoquait sa avec les
experts avancent peu de fair play
républicains pour pour féliciter le
vainqueur et lui donner un quand même un
quitus savait écouter les chiffres je
pense sont claires il est très heureux
que marine le pen soit battu c'était la
position que nous avions eues depuis le
premier tour mais les chiffres montrent
effectivement que emmanuel macron est le
plus mal élu de la vème république on
peut tourner ça dans tous les sens alors
selon don se situe on n'aura pas la même
interprétation mais les faits sont là et
puis surtout je vous rappelle qu'il ya
cinq ans ce même nouveau président avait
été élu pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite cinq ans plus tard il ya eu deux
candidatures proéminente d'extrême
droite donc il a travaillé pour faire en
sorte que marine le pen au second tour
il a eu le second tour qu'il souhaitait
pour pouvoir être élu et puis madame
madame le pen a joué le rôle d'assurance
vie du système donc elle a permis de
maquereau de pouvoir être élu donc n'ont
aucun des éléments de la crise
économique sociale et démocratique qui
travaillent ce pays qui le fracture même
parfois ne sont résolus par cette
réélection vous avez vu le chiffre de
l'abstention qui est en hausse et donc
il y aura un troisième tour qui devrait
déterminer effectivement quel programme
avec 7,5 g au service d'intérêts
généraux de voix c'est à dire en
pourcentage d'inscrits il est mieux et
luc françois hollande par exemple ou que
jacques chirac et s'agissant de
l'extrême droite et c'est intéressant de
souligner qu' il ait eu aussi beaucoup
de discours tout sauf macron et une très
grande ambiguïté y compris d'ailleurs de
la france insoumise ça n'a pas été un
appel à un barrage républicain classique
on dit votez macro et je le comprends je
ne critique pas mais ça a été plutôt un
mini et donc forcément dans le mini on
n'a pas tout à fait même nombre de voix
mais si on parle en nombre de voix et
pourcentage d'inscrits les chiffres sont
têtus et je pense ça fait partie des
choses à avoir bien en tête il est mieux
mais très bien que soient vos liens
votre barrage jetterait acquis belgique
et donc il n'y a pas un vote d'adhésion
pour ce nouveau président vous le savez
très bien et vous allez le voir seul est
et nous le verrons législatives et nous
le verrons dans la rue parce que vous
pouvez sûr que après avoir mis en échec
votre tentative par exemple de réforme
des retraites qui était opposée par la
majorité de la population nous avons
fait ce travail à l'assemblée il y à une
mobilisation dans la rue dont vous
pouvez être sûr que la rue sera au
rendez vous pour empêcher
démocratique et ils seront servis
entendez aussi le
d'adhésion qui ce qui se jouera ce sera
aux législatives gérard longuet je vous
donne la parole dans un tout petit
instant mais nous partons tout de suite
je suis se trouve mais je vais vous
donner la parole où se trouve l amont
d'un gamin il est soutien d' emmanuel
macron est là le président est arrivé
n'ont toujours pas il se fait toujours
attendre il est annoncé autour de 21h30
alors vers 21h tout le monde s'est tu et
en fait c'était parce que la tour eiffel
derrière moi comment c'est à scintiller
il faut dire qu'au début ça dansait il y
avait beaucoup d'ambiance et puis ça
fait tout de même une heure que les
résultats comparu et bien on attend
toujours une prise de parole du
président de la république alors ici
évidemment vous pouvez vous en douter un
les militants sont soulagés soulagé
puisque leur candidat est réélu
président de la république évidemment et
puis surtout parce que l'écart avec
marine le pen est assez conséquent alors
vous avez débattu sur le plateau en des
différentes déclarations des uns et des
autres des anciens candidats à
l'élection présidentielle de son
opposante marine le pen ici il n'en est
rien puisque il n'y a pas d'écran géant
qui diffuse ses réactions
seulement une scène un pupitre on en
attend évidemment derrière nous la tour
eiffel c'est le décor qu'elle choisit
emmanuel macron pour sa victoire merci
mandingue avec steven martens au
champ-de-mars à un mot très très rapide
sur votre estimation que vous faites
évoluer un tout petit peu oui mais qu'on
serait sur 58 5% des voix pour emmanuel
macron et moi c'est une
grande voix là il arrive sur des
remontées des d'accord une victoire qui
reste quand même assez nette gérard
longuet je vous donne la parole on voit
aujourd'hui une élection d' emmanuel
macron assez nette on se souvient de
gérard larcher qui avait parlé de
légitimité pour cette élection
légitimité du vote quand vous voyez les
scores ce soir quand vous voyez aussi
l'abstention les votes nuls qu'est ce
que vous dites
que ce n'était pas la meilleure d'un
intervention de gérard larcher je pense
profondément qu'un élu est un élu le
taux de participation est un objectif on
souhaite avoir le maximum de voix pour
avoir le maximum d'autorité mais le
président emmanuel macron vient d'être
réélu largement réélu on peut en effet
réfléchir à la cohésion de son électorat
et c'est un débat qui qui s'impose vous
l'avez évoqué vous l'avez évoqué nous
l'évoquerons nous n'avons pas un
électorat parfaitement cohérent c'est
d'ailleurs le choix des manuels macro
lui même puisqu'il est à la fois dedans
et dehors assez souvent il est et en
même temps et vous avez évoqué
madame manière une hache et des sujets
qui sont majeurs par exemple l'écologie
qui me passionne pour la décarbonation
rapide de notre industrie en particulier
les solutions de sont parmi les
électeurs du maniema qu'on ne sont pas
toutes les mêmes sur l'âge de la
retraite que vous avez évoquées moi je
suis pour le pouvoir d'achat que pour le
pouvoir d'achat ils vont travailler plus
et la france est un pays où on travaille
pas assez on va pas refaire le débat
posé continue de parfaitement tôt posé
sur ce sujet mais ce que je sais c'est
que dans l'électorat d'emmanuel macron
moi j'ai voté pour lui à cause du
nucléaire et pour la retraite à 60 ans
ouvrier j'attends est ce que vous
pourriez travailler avec aussi deux
points est ce que vous pourriez
travailler avec nous engageait pas
forcément et l'air mais c'est ce que je
disais de l'agneau ennaji sénateurs moi
j'ai toujours beauté comme d'ailleurs
mes collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
des textes qui nous paraissait aller
dans le sens de nos convictions et de
l'intérêt national
ça me pose aucun problème je savais que
les institutions de la vème et mélenchon
a raison de le rappeler ce sont des
institutions parlementaires pourrait
aller jusque une discussion un accord de
gouvernement éventuel rsa c'est un deux
et c'est là le vrai problème d' emmanuel
macron saura-t-il gérer le caractère
hétérogène de son électorat en
respectant les uns et des autres et on
ne choisissant pas dé collection de
scalps tous aussi flatteurs les uns que
les autres mais en s'orientant vers une
solution de type parlementaire et en
europe puisque président l'europe
actuellement on a des exemples exemple
plus célèbres c'est la main vide
allemand l'allemagne ou d'une coalition
se forme après plusieurs semaines de
débats bien moi cela me rassurerait
parce que ça donnerait plus d'autorité
au président mais le président est élu
c'est pas vraiment dans notre culture
française en tout cas peut-être si l'on
tue travailler ensemble plutôt une
source
à un espagnol une hache est ce que vous
en pensez est ce qu'une coalition vous
semble possible est ce que vous pourriez
travailler
avec effectivement des républicains où
le parti socialiste mais je crois qu'il
faut qu alice forte un projet aux
élections législatives enfin je veux
dire c'est aux français de choisir qui
veulent porter à l'ascendant et
l'association c'est un accord de
gouvernement entre différentes parties
la partie reggae boyz là et moi il me
semble que la première étape c'est
porter un projet et après on verra se
porter ce projet je lui dis il tourne
autour de quatre priorités ses quatre
priorités autant je pense que le
président de la république est ouvert à
discuter des idées justement est
peut-être à préciser certains points sur
l'écologie comme vous le dites sur la
décarbonation l'industrie pour en parler
des heures je crois qu on y est on a une
vision très claire de comment on veut
mener ce projet décarbonation et on fait
partie des rares nations qui sont en
avance par rapport aux accords de paris
je me repose sur la décarbonation nature
et les éléments fondamentaux de la soul
r&b n'importe quoi je pourrais vivre
chez soi si vous le souhaitez sur sur la
question de la santé sur la question
l'école je crois que les français nous à
nous attendre et qu'il faut rentrer dans
la profondeur du projet et vous savez
qu'on avait indiqué qu on était prêt à
concerter mais pas seulement avec
d'autres formations politiques mais avec
les français venus avec les français
qu'avec d'autres partis politiques
j'entends bien après il ya l'autre
manière de poser la question qui est
comment gouverne et je crois que et on
l'a montré sur des textes parlementaires
récents c'est à dire trouver des points
d'équilibré qui permette justement de
tenir compte d'avancés qui peuvent être
portés par un amendement par tél alors
qu'on adore ça c'est assez amusant cette
image de françois bayrou et de manuel
valls l'un à côté de l'autre champ de
mars ils attendent l'arrivée d' emmanuel
macron qui va s'exprimer d'ici un quart
d'heure à peu près 120
on verra bien et elsa monde ingrat qui
est avec barbara pompili la ministre de
la transition écologique on les écoute
tout de suite 7 en direct
déjà une première réaction ce score
l'écart est plus important qu'espéré ce
que c'est un soulagement tout d'abord
oui terme ans le score est clair les
français souhaitent que le président
fasse un deuxième mandat et là il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté possible c'était le
premier objectif de cette soirée
maintenant l'extrême droite est haute il
y à une abstention forte et donc les
français ont pris nos responsabilités en
allant voter y compris pour quelqu'un
qui n'avait pas choisi au premier tour
maintenant à nous aussi d'avoir cette
responsabilité de rassembler pendant
second quinquennat de me mettre tout le
monde à la tâche quelque part pour
construire ce monde qu'on doit
construire ensemble justement on a
entendu lors de la soirée marine le pen
salué son propre score à elles sont
forcément félicité le chef de l'état
eric zemmour jean luc mélenchon donné
aussi rendez vous pour le troisième tour
pour les législatives pour vous ils sont
mauvais perdants ou cette élection là
même la particularité de laisser
beaucoup de gens sur leur faim
d'abord
je trouve que ça manque un peu
d'élégance et de sens républicain mais
malheureusement je n'avais pas trop
d'espoir de ce côté là maintenant oui
c'est vrai il faut que président à une
majorité pour faire ces réformes est
donc ce sera la bataille qu'on va
commencer dès demain pour les
législatives mais vous savez quand on
voit les inquiétudes qui se sont
exprimées moi je les ai entendus on est
allé sur le terrain on a bien entendu
même des colères qui pouvait vous pouvez
vous exprimer elle reflète quoi il faut
qu'on analyse bien moi je crois qu'elle
reflète un sentiment d'une certaine
partie de nos concitoyens qui ne se
sentent pas entraîner dans ce mouvement
que on est en train de construire tous
ensemble la transition écologique elle
peut être source d'inquiétude les gens
peuvent se dire ouh la la qu'est ce que
c'est que cette contrainte à nous de les
comptes de construire avec eux pour que
ça devienne une source d'espoir pour
montrer qu'on est en train de construire
ce monde qui sera un monde meilleur où
on vivra mieux nous et nos enfants
justement dernière question sur
l'écologie emmanuel macron a fait
beaucoup de promesses certains disent
ben pourquoi croire que pendant les cinq
prochaines années il fera finalement ce
qu'il n'a pas fait pendant les cinq
dernières d'abord parce que c'est
totalement faux de dire qu'il n'a rien
fait on a multiplié par deux la vitesse
de réduction d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre depuis le dernier le début du
précédent quinquennat donc maintenant il
faut encore accéléré moi qui suis
écologiste je peux vous dire il faut
accélérer encore doubler l'effort on a
mis en place les bases dans différentes
lois qu'on aime qu'on a voté dans le
précédent quinquennat maintenant il faut
y aller faut mettre en place c'est pour
ça qu'on a besoin de planification
on a besoin de donner une visibilité y
compris au monde de nos entreprises et
il faut qu'on fasse territoire par
territoire ce que vous n'avez pas les
mêmes enjeux chez moi à amiens ou à
paris ou dans la corrèze ou au bord de
la méditerranée donc c'est un travail à
faire mais il faut qu'on le fasse tous
ensemble personne ne doit être laissé
sur le côté
la transition écologique sera sociale le
président l'a dit maintenant on va le
mettre en oeuvre merci beaucoup madame
les ministes dans quelques une dizaine
de minutes peut-être on attend le chef
de l'état qui va s'exprimer juste
derrière nous dans la tour eiffel merci
à mon gars va et surtout vous nous
faites signe dès que le président de la
république vous rejoins au champ de mars
philippe ballard nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir bienvenue vous vous êtes
porte-parole du rassemblement national
on a écouté marine le pen son premier
discours juste après les résultats elle
parle d'une éclatante victoire pour
autant vous êtes battus ce soir ben
tiens tout d'abord à remercier les
traits plus 13 millions sans doute un
français qui ont apporté leurs suffrages
à marine le pen c'est un gain de plus de
2 millions 500 mille voix par rapport à
2010 est quand dans le même temps
emmanuel mac on perd deux millions trois
cent mille électeurs voilà oui mais vous
les avez quand même perdu mais on a on
peut pas nier l'évidence je vous
l'accordé ce qu'il a fait venir c'est
une éclatante victoire à part ce 42 43 %
ge pas où en sont les derniers
dernière innovation je suis
le problème à l'écran qui vient
d'arriver au changement
voilà jamais ce courant de pensée n'a
été aussi fort et surtout je pense que
ce soir sa selle définitivement le
clivage qui structurent la vie politique
française mondialistes d'un côté incarné
par emmanuel macron et puis les
nationaux de l'autre et il ya quelques
instants j'ai tant débat avec un olivier
ferrand ministre de la santé et qui
disait mais on va s'attaquer à présent
dans ce quinquennat aux causes de tous
qui fracturent la société française
socialement économiquement
d'un point de vue identitaire mais c'est
pas possible parce qu'en fait vous avez
cette vision mondialiste et vous croyez
au libre échange vous croyez à
l'ouverture des frontières que ce soit
pour les biens les marchandises les
personnes et donc non ce quinquennat
alors il ya des législatives je pense
qu'on pourra en parler avec sa
délicieuse je pense qu'il a très vite
commencé ce soir donc avec cette vision
pourra pas résorber toutes ses phrases
durerait pendant sa nièce pagnol sinon
moi je crois pas en la préférence
nationale 7 5 je crois pas
la préférence nationale la remise en
cause du droit d'asile et toutes ces
choses qui sont est désolé de le redire
qu'ils sont des marqueurs de l'extrême
droite l'extrême droite n'a pas changé
elle est pour un repli sur les
frontières et en plus c'est une atteinte
à ce que sont profondément nos valeurs
républicaines et je pense à l'article
1er est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme je pense que si on mettait en
oeuvre la politique de marine le pen ou
perdrait tous les talents de les marie
curie cnam est plus grave vous avez fait
l'essentiel de votre campagne sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur des mesures que
quand on est des analyses ne tiennent
pas la route elle ne fonctionne pas et
c'est ça que je trouve une imposture
profonde parce qu'au fond
le pouvoir d'achat c'est évidemment une
préoccupation forte des français mais si
on arrive sans solution il va se passer
quoi et je parle pas de l'écologie ou là
rien s'il n'y a rien sur l'écologie par
l'écologiste ne nous faisait monter au
nez vous démange alors évidemment c'est
tout vous avez
fermé ses vannes ou second tour assez
mal lamentable qui a eu lieu je pense
que la question c'est que c'est que
c'est que oui
ça m'a tenté de vous parler de la
question de l'immigration une des
premiers textes que vous avez fait voter
à l'assemblée nationale c'est noisy
l'immigration qui est énoncé par toutes
les organisations de défense des droits
humains vous croyez
soit ayant été emprunté un extrême
heureusement je leur envoie pas de leur
âge et je mets en cause par cette
dernière
met en cause les cinq dernières années
où vous avez appliqué des mesures anti
immigrants des mesures islamophobe qui
ont alimenté qui ont alimenté l'explorer
abondent par ailleurs par ailleurs moi
ce qui m'interpelle 6 tentant de madame
pompidou quand le giec dit qu'il nous
reste trois ans pour mettre en oeuvre
les mesures immédiates nécessaires pour
faire face aux changements climatiques
et qu'on sait que vous n'avez respecté
aucun des éléments fondamentaux de
l'accord de paris on voit bien que vous
n'êtes pas à la hauteur vous n'êtes pas
à la hauteur et heureusement
heureusement au premier tour cet ancien
premier ministre français doit bien sûr
je peux avoir levé le fait que désormais
tout le monde parle de planification
sens au beausset et perdent
donc on a commencé à faire avancer les
éléments du langage mais la grâce à
l'essai
il faut avoir un compte il suffit pas de
voler les mots pour remettre la
politique et le matin
si on regarde les accords de paris deux
minutes pourquoi sommes-nous en retard
sur les énergies renouvelables
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on déploie des
énergies non renouvelables nous avons
des contentieux et nous sommes un grand
pays une grande démocratie et le temps
devant le juge ralenti ce déploiement
turquie qui a voté contre qui a voté
contre la loi qui permettait d'accélérer
le traitement de ces contentieux la
france insoumise là aussi vous avez
parfum d'allemand et réservé était
d'accélérer les la loi sur
l'accélération ça faisait filmer sommes
nous sommes le seul pays en décembre ne
pas avoir respecté un train
l'augmentation des énergies
renouvelables ça se fait en europe ce
moment bien sûr banal bois
d'amont peu d'amis stephanie aménagerait
alesi donc vous votez contre les lois
qui permettent d'accélérer le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
quoi la loi asap laissant leur 2020
choisir envoie vous lirez elle est très
intéressante
continuer est pareils à jeune afrique en
fait votre positionnement consiste à
dire c'est nul rien n'y a fait ces
criminels et de
mépris et beml dans un programme à
quelque chose d'autre les chefs vous
avez voté
alors ça arrive souvent dans les débats
et un moment où il faut élever la voix
pour reprendre la main c'est maintenant
elle a passé à gérard longuet peut-être
sur cette thématique de de la transition
écologique est ce que c'est pour vous le
chantier majeur prioritaire de ce second
quinquennat des mamelles mac jeu je
crois que vous allez trop vite je crois
que vous allez trop vite nous avons un
président qui est élu et qui doit
préparer des élections législatives nous
sommes sur public sénat nous connaissons
le droit constitutionnel et la france a
un mode d'une constitution parlementaire
et donc il faut que le président il y a
deux mois et dans la vie politique
d'aujourd'hui deux mois c'est long il
faut que le président rassembler une
majorité madame panière une hache et
nous dit mais ce sont les électeurs sur
les projets qui vont la forme et avec en
oubliant n'oubliez pas cependant que
nous avons un système où il y aura peu
de participation l'a vu la dernière fois
et un scrutin majoritaire dont les
effets sont extrêmement brutaux le peu
de participation fait que tout les
candidats qui n'ont pas 25% des inscrits
le ciel ne participeront pas au deuxième
tour c'est un peu contre vous doute je
veux dire pardon je veux dire travail
que l'intérêt du président et s'il veut
respecter les gens qui l'ont élu c'est
de parler avec eux avant les
législatives et non pas après nous
aurions la proportionnelle que vous
souhaitez que je j'accepte volontiers on
pourrait attendre la proportionnelle
comme en allemagne en effet où les gens
votent alors vous avez 22% ben vous en
avez pour vos 22 bourse en mai en france
vous avez 25 vous avez tous vous avez 22
vous n'avez rien et ça c'est un système
qui n'est pas qui n'est plus acceptable
par l'opinion parce que quel que soit le
brio de l'élection d' emmanuel macron il
a été élu par des gens qui veulent des
choses différentes il ya quand même un
moment où il faut trancher cela et il
vaut mieux le trancher avant les
élections qu après des élections sinon
il aura cinq ans de solitude vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que disait nicolas
sarkozy il faut se rapprocher des
manuels mâcon j'ai finalement c'est la
droite qui est au pouvoir c'est le cas
tellement se rapprocher de l'homme c'est
de mettre en place des institutions qui
permettent la coopération en france il
n'ya pas de parti majoritaire dans ce
pays il y a des gens qui peuvent
travailler ensemble et des gens qui ne
peuvent pas travailler ensemble il faut
permettre à ceux qui peuvent travailler
ensemble de travailler dans le respect
mutuel les plus importants doivent être
considérées les moins importants qui
sont utiles doivent être considérées
alors la question elle se pose aussi de
ce côté de l'échiquier pas là le
problème du rassemblement national oui
mais alors connaître à écouter c'est
quand même sa solitude voilà abattu
selon l'étude à 44% mais
[Musique]
parce que c'est intéressant d'écouter un
extrait du discours d'eric zemmour tout
à l'heure justement puisqu'on parle de
solitude ou d'accords ou d'union des
droites écouter ce que proposait le
candidat reconquête eric zemmour après
avoir dit ça fait 8 fois que la famille
le pen est battu il propose quand même
une alliance écouter
situation politique d'aujourd'hui nous
impose d'agir les élections législatives
qui viennent en juin prochain voit déjà
la constitution de deux grands blocs
politiques autour d' emmanuel macron et
de jean luc mélenchon veut bloc l'homme
acronis tlo autre islamo-gauchiste deux
blocs qui s'organise se rassemblent et
s'apprêtent à s'affronter dans un match
qui n'aura à coup sûr qu'un seul perdant
la france le camp national serait-il
donc le seul à ne pas être capable de
s'unir voulons nous donner les pleins
pouvoirs à emmanuel macron et jean luc
mélenchon
je ne le veux pas le bloc national doit
lui aussi s'unir et se rassembler notre
responsabilité est immense
c'est pour cela que j'appelle à l'union
nationale en vue des législatives
philippe ballard que répondez-vous à cet
appel d'eric zemmour est ce qu'il faut
finalement lancer une négociation pour
avoir des candidats communs aux
législatives alors c'est très clair il y
aura des candidats et rennes une carte
d'adhérent et rennes partout en france
il y aura aussi des candidats soutenus
par le rassemblement national mais ce
qui est très clair au suisse et qu'il
n'y aura pas d'accord de parti à parti
un départ éclair reconquête soutenu par
l'enjeu les passionnés y avoir des
conditions qui n'ont pas une carte et
rennes qui ne sont pas adhérents mais
qui pourront être soutenues mais pas
d'accent sur ce que l'on a avec eric
zemmour c'est que lui continue dans sa
voix d'union des droits marine le pen
l'a dit avant le premier tour avant le
deuxième tour et on va leur dire mon des
législatives nous sommes pour l'union
des populaires qu'ils soient de droite
de gauche du centre ou d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup trop parlons pas l'expression
mais c'est un peu petit bras d'être pour
l'union des droites ça regroupe pas
assez non vie le quinquennat qui vient
de s'achever celui qui débute on espère
bien qu'il y aura une cohabitation fin
juin il faut réunir tout le monde qu'on
soit de droite de gauche du sont marie
le pen disait il ya quelques jours je ne
crois pas qu'on ne donne pas de majorité
un président sortant maintenant vous
espérez une cohabitation abonde us avec
un film où en général ne vous mais
gérard longuet le rappela effectuant le
scrutin uninominal à deux tours voilà
est beaucoup moins favorable que la
proportionnelle ces comptes ont fait 13
millions de voix peut prévoir un peu
plus ce soir on pourra avoir un groupe
parlementaire parce que face à emmanuel
macron la seule opposition c'est la
nôtre c'est plus la france a soumises là
c'est la france soumise bah oui quand on
appelle à voter emmanuel macron c'est la
retraite à 65 ans voilà par exemple si
par malheur le monastère avec
l'annoncé de sa sentence
pour mener le mac on peut commencer à 20
ans et finir à 65 ans est ce qu'il y
aller car cette fois c'est donc dans le
camp des réalistes face à la retraite
face à celui j'ai déjà politique
la question
de fait le nom découvert que vous le
vouliez ou non le match vers je suis
profondément patriote j'aime mon pays
vous aussi j'en suis persuadé vous aussi
madame mais la seule façon de lui donner
son indépendance et sa force c'est de
lui donner la capacité d'être au niveau
de ses concurrents et il faut donc
travailler pour cela et nous travaillons
moins que les autres et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je soutenais à la
proposition alors
travail est fondamentale oui monsieur le
pen
décentralisation et pour la famille quoi
cette règle est voilà très bien on peut
avoir des points d'accord mais les
phrases que vous la droite extrême
droite
une phrase je faisais que ça parlait
en fait vous continuez nous vendent
cette mondialisation qu'on nous
présentait comme exil a mis en
compétition non on revient en arrière en
vous par des navires ou européenne veut
mettre de lax car
vous avez notre côté je trouverais leur
donner les dix et on nous a mis en
compétition avec des pays qui ne sont
pas pas les mêmes râler fiscales
environnementales mais vous savez très
bien on revient en arrière j'ai bien vu
merci bien merci bien parce que
effectivement la vie bon là on a la
droite et on voit les convergences
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de la droite
anciennement gaulliste et républicaine
avec la droite néolibérale de monsieur
mâcon violent et l'extrême droite égal à
égal à égal à égal à elle même et puis
aujourd'hui effectivement il y à un
troisième bloc
représenter à l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour par jean
luc mélenchon 22% une union populaire
comme on l'apporté qui est l'alternative
véritable à la politique de monsieur
macro comme celle de madame le pen et
son association ce qu'on a consenti
sociaux honda mais dès que l'on pose les
bases de ce que nous on a construit
c'est d'abord un programme un programme
de bifurcation écologique réelle de
planification un programme au service du
plus grand nombre oui nous assumons
d'être pour la retraite à 60 ans avec 40
annuités oui parce que les français et
les françaises les français les français
je travaille travaille très dur il y en
a même qui travaillent en vivant sous le
seuil de pauvreté et c'est ça le sujet
majeur et on peut la payer désolé on se
la payer et et on peut le payer si on
partage et c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui
quand on sait les yeux de tous les
ateliers n'existe pas et les milliards
et les milliards du cac 40 ou des
ultra-riches la richesse elle est
produite par les mêmes travailleurs et
travailleuses que vous voulez faire
travailler jusqu'au tombeau donc vous
voyez il ya clairement oui une autre
voie ce n'est pas les réalistes contre
les utopistes voulait qu'aujourd'hui la
réalité des gens qui travaillent jusqu'à
en mourir parce que aujourd'hui un quart
des personnes les plus pauvres de ce
pays meurt avant 62 ans alors il ya
nationaux et donc c est donc cette vidéo
donc c'est la personnalité remettre ça
vous appelez voter pour lui moi j'avoue
qu'il ya les
quatre
médailles quand
la compagne de l'homme serait-il soit
lormand vous allez faire avec une mesure
qui divise autant le voit sur ce plateau
d'abord parce qu'elle est caricaturé
mais je veux juste dire une chose madame
aubenas n'a pas le monopole de la gauche
un pardon territoire de progrès
mais bien sûr sur la figure exactement
pour ça que la gauche est devenue un
mode toxiques parce que des gens comme
vous comme monsieur mamadou perdre un
bâillon histoire oui mais et c'est rien
du territoire où j'habite vous ne
connaissez les valeurs humaines et
politiques de droit n'en prenant je ne
crois pas de l'extrême droite je ne vois
pas qui avait fait monter là j'ai su
manier telenor dans l'autre
extrême droite et nous nous sommes le
blog est celle qui est la meilleure a
dit que j'étais à z par holt mais
assumez les
comment
en tout cas daniel rey n'ont jamais su
le mois de juin les parages de la neige
mais l'inconnue n'y a pas de séparation
mais efficace ça me rassure
pardonnez moi je vous redonne la main un
petit instant et
maîtrisée sur
sarenza monde à gava vous êtes sur place
avec les soutiens des manuels macron il
ya beaucoup d'ambiance sur les images
que nous pouvons voir beaucoup de monde
effectivement au champ de mars vous nous
entendez emmanuel macron est il arrivé
[Musique]
écoutez son arrivée est imminente
puisque le speaker a annoncé la foule
vient de se taire on entend l'hymne
européen
et emmanuel macron donc devrait arriver
on a vu un dans la foule voilà regardez
vous le voyez sur l'écran la
scénographie soignée il est accompagné
de sa femme brigitte macron et puis
d'une trentaine de jeunes regardez cette
image du président de la république
réélu la tour eiffel symbole par
excellence de paris connue dans le monde
entier et puis ces jeunes c'est le
message qui emmanuel macron a choisi ce
soir pour son nouveau mandat et bien
c'est d'être entouré de jeunes gens la
jeunesse il l'a répété plusieurs fois
elle a souffert pendant le coc vide
c'est donc eu une image forte qui est
présenté emmanuel macron tout sourire
avec à son bras évidemment la première
dame brigitte macron
il arrive là dans la salle évidemment
tout le monde se tait alors tout le
monde a sorti les téléphones portables
vous pouvez vous en douter et on voit au
loin je sais pas si vous voyez sous un
des piliers de la tour eiffel là on
aperçoit au loin et bien ce convoi du
président de la république de sa son
épouse brigitte macron et puis de ces
jeunes voilà je vous laisse écouter
regarder il y a encore peut-être 50 100
m qui va séparer le président de la
république de la foule de ses militants
continuer de partager ses images avec
les téléspectateurs de nos chaînes
parlementaires et peut-être aussi une
espagne et aux usa chez les commenter il
avait choisi qu'on peut dire tomac qui
rappelle aussi cette arrivée à la
pyramide du louvre et moins solitaire
cinq ans
effectivement c'est moins solitaire mais
une arrivée avec un différentes pour
être honnête parce que il était vraiment
un homme seul avait le côté jupitérien
dans sa mise en scène de dix à cinq ans
la il a fait le choix d'être entendus et
c'était aussi l'espagne wind hachez le
les derniers mots de son de sa carte
blanche à la fin du débat mais bien mais
je crois que
il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que
nous avons l'intention d'ouvrir d'ouvrir
notre gouvernement d'ouvrir notre
programme je les dis la question n'est
pas de savoir quelles sont les
opérations d'appareils qui vont se
passer ici et là la question est de
savoir quel projet on veut porter et le
projet que nous voulons porter c'est
celui de la social démocratie c'est
celui de beaucoup de maires madame qui
viennent de la gauche qui nous
rejoignent à territoire de progrès et
c'est une gauche et c'est une gauche et
un centre droit et un centre gauche qui
assume de regarder les faits tels qu'ils
sont c'est à dire que c'est jaurès 1 qui
qui disait ça qui parlait de allié idéal
et comprendre le réel et je pense et je
pense je ne bulle comme tout le monde et
il m'a inspiré comme tout le monde mais
là aussi pas de monopole s'il vous plaît
mais un espagnol une action voit bien
qu'il ya des coalitions qui sont en
train de se dé alliance des opérations
outils qui sont en tout cas souhaité
laissant à à droite ou à la droite de la
droite à l'extrême droite vous nous
soumettez exemple dans l'imaginaire
aussi parce que on voit quand même
gérard longuet qui semble assez proche
de vos idées vous souhaitez aussi
quelques proches de 6 j'ai dit que si
emmanuel macron doute une majorité
parlementaire sont un tesson de voir ces
deux-là préparer parce que sinon il ya
un candidat par circonscription qui
arrivera en tête c'est celui qui porte
la casaque de madame le pen et vous
aurez trois autres candidats le vôtre
celui de
emmanuel macron il sans doute le nôtre
qui a une existence et une implantation
qui a ri qui seront derrière et qui
seront sans doute éliminer est-ce que
vous par le salut douze ennemis pour
cent des instruments s'avère un produit
réflexion qui n'est pas conduite se
terminer juste tout s'est compliqué ce
que jeudi toute alliance qui n'est pas
construite avant l'élection peut
permettre à marine le pen d'avoir une
majorité bien entendu vous aurez
l'occasion pendant un instant je
retourne pardon je retourne au champ de
mars avec examonde un gars va donc le
prenne en mains publiques apprend qui
est en train de saluer des militants
c'est ça
exactement des militants et des soutiens
aussi on voit des personnes qui font
partie de l'équipe de la campagne là il
y as je dirais une vingtaine de mètres
qui le séparent encore du pupitre il ya
un espace qui a été prévu après pour
qu'ils puissent traverser la foule et
effectivement on a vu emmanuel macron
avec son épouse brigitte macron entouré
d'une trentaine de jeunes des
adolescents et même des très très jeune
là il salue longuement des militants des
ministres aussi on l'a vu salué le
ministre des affaires européennes
clément bonne il s'attarde évidemment
pour saluer la foule alors il ya un
grand silence un dans la foule on entend
parfois quelques slogans mais vraiment
là tout le monde se tait tout le monde
attend donc que le président de la
république fini ce sont ces salles us et
remerciements très certainement et
attendre son discours un discours qui
est calibré pour durer une quinzaine de
minutes nous dit on mais vous voyez
emmanuel macron a pas l'air pressé
évidemment de rejoindre le pupitre ils
saluent et bien tous ceux qui l'ont
soutenu pendant cette campagne une
campagne difficile une campagne
particulière évidemment et voilà ça
continue toujours au lendemain tu
toujours avec cette scénographie devant
la tour eiffel illuminée dans la nuit
noire
emmanuel macron qui n'est pas arrivé
seul contrairement à il ya cinq ans on
s'en souvient sur la pyramide du louvre
la 7e accompagné entouré de son épouse
entourés de jeunes et on entend la
clameur des militants qui attendent
depuis une heure et demie leur champion
ici au champ de mars tout est là vous
êtes donc au champ-de-mars où vous voyez
le président de la république l'acquis
qui font la foule qui est arrivé donc
vous nous disiez avec les enfants à le
avec vous qu'on avait pu voir en slogan
dans cette campagne présidentielle est
ce que vous avez pu apercevoir les
soutiens du président de la république
les poids lourds de la république en
marche du modem l'ancien premier
ministre par exemple
[Musique]
monde un gars voient qu'ils semblent pas
du tout nous entendre alors que vous
voyez à l'image est bien le président
emmanuel macron réélu huitième président
de la vème république ce soir ils font
la foule les salue effectivement tous
les supporters qui sont venus ce soir et
les nombreux soutiens qu'on a pu
apercevoir tout à l'heure effectivement
jean castex françois bayrou on a aperçu
manuel valls qui était également aux
côtés de françois bayrou et puis de
nombreux ministres qui doivent également
être sur place il va prononcer un
discours dans une quinzaine de minutes
maintenant qui doit durer une quinzaine
de minutes
combien de temps
prendra t-il pour arriver au pupitre et
prendre la parole dont on le verra bien
c'est un peu le paradoxe de cette soirée
on a un emmanuel macron qui est réélu
avec un large écart sur marine le pen
qui est le premier président dans
l'histoire de cette 5ème république à
être réélu sans être en cohabitation
puisqu'évidemment françois mitterrand
puis jacques chirac avait été réélue
mais il n'était pas au pouvoir il dit il
était en période de cohabitation donc
c'est vraiment le paradoxe de cette
soirée on a les mêmes écrans qui rentre
dans l'histoire on peut c'est factuel en
étant le premier élu dans ces conditions
et qui fait face c'était vraiment la
tonalité des prises de paroles d d d
autres candidats à cette présidentielle
qui fait face à une opposition frontale
exprimer
dès les premières minutes
d'abord par marine le pen puis par jean
luc mélenchon
tribune thomas au président qui va sans
doute s'exprimer dans les prochaines
secondes à présent
[Applaudissements]
emmanuel macron qui va faire face à un
vrai défi voilà on l'a dit il ya une
abstention très fort ce soir
28,2 % des français ne sont pas allés
voter et il ya aussi tous ceux qui ont
voté pour lui plus tôt on l'a vu avec
d'autres instituts de sondage ipsos
sopra et steria pour faire barrage à
marine le pen le défi est de taille pour
le président de la république emmanuel
macron réunissent ce soir par 58 il dit
mes chers amis
chers compatriotes
ici à paris
et partout à travers le territoire en
hexagone dans nos outre mer comme à
l'étranger
oui avant toute chose merci
[Applaudissements]
après cinq années
de transformation de rezé difficile de
crise exceptionnelle aussi
ce jour du 24 avril 2022 une majorité
d'entre nous a fait le choix de me faire
confiance pour président de notre
république
durant les cinq années à venir
[Applaudissements]
alors je veux remercier l'ensemble des
militants des volontaires
des compagnons de route et lui qui
depuis le début ma compagne et ont rendu
cette élection possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que vous n'avez pas ménager vos
efforts avait donné tant d'énergie
partagé tant de conviction
c'est en frappant au coeur que vient la
vérité
merci et je sais ce que je vous dois
merci
[Applaudissements]
je leur sied
l'ensemble des à celle des français
qui au premier puis un deuxième tour
m'ont accordé leur confiance afin de
faire advenir notre projet pour une
france plus indépendante une europe plus
forte et par des investissements et des
changements profonds continuer d'assurer
les progrès concrets pour chacun en
libérant la créativité l'innovation dans
notre pays et pour faire de la france
une grande nation écologique
[Applaudissements]
je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
et je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote mobilisent pour
les années à venir
je suis dépositaire
de leur sens du devoir
de leur attachement à la république et
du respect des différences qui se sont
exprimés ces dernières semaines
je pense aussi à tous nos compatriotes
qui se sont abstenus
leur silence a signifié un refus de
choisir
auquel nous nous devrons aussi de
répondre
je pense enfin à ceux qui ont voté pour
madame le pen dont je sais la déception
de ce soir non le cediv les personnes
depuis le début je vous ai demandé de ne
jamais sifflé
[Applaudissements]
parce
dès à présent
je suis plus le candidat d'un camp mais
le président de toutes et tous
et je sais comme pour nombre de nos
compatriotes
qui ont choisi aujourd'hui l'extrême
droite la colère et les désaccords qui
les ont conduits à voter pour ce projet
doivent aussi trouver une réponse ce
sera ma responsabilité et celle de ceux
qui m'entourent
[Applaudissements]
car le vote de ce jour
nous impose de considérer toutes les
difficultés des vies vécues et de
répondre avec efficacité aux colère qui
se sont exprimées
mes chers compatriotes mes chers amis
aujourd'hui
vous avez fait le choix d'un projet
humaniste ambitieux pour l'indépendance
de notre pays pour notre or un projet
républicain dans ses valeurs un projet
social et écologique
un projet fondé sur le travail
et la création un projet de libération
de nos forces la télé mais culturel
entreprenariale
ce projet
[Musique]
ce projet je veux le porter avec force
pour les années qui viennent
en étant dépositaires aussi
des divisions qui se sont exprimés et
des différences et en veillant chaque
jour au respect de chacun et en
continuant de vrai à une société plus
juste et à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
[Applaudissements]
alors pour cela il nous faudrait
exigeant et ambitieux
nous avons tant à faire
et la garenne est là pour nous rappeler
que nous traversons des temps tragique
où la france se doit de porter sa voix
de montrer la clarté de ses choix
et de bâtir sa force dans tous les
domaines et nous le serons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il faudra aussi mais allait être
bienveillant et respectueux car notre
pays est pétri de temps de doute le
temps de divisions
alors il nous faudra être fort
mais nul ne sera laissé au bord du
chemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il nous reviendra un simple
devrait cette unité par laquelle seuls
ne pourront vivre plus heureux en france
et relever les défis qui nous attendent
les années à venir à coup sûr
ne seront pas tranquilles
mais elles seront historiques et
ensemble nous aurons à les écrire pour
le génération
elle a les siennes compatriotes
mes chers compatriotes
c'est avec l'ambition et bienveillance
pour notre pays pour nous tout ce
que je veux pouvoir à vos côtés
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
cette ère nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refonder pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays de notre
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
chacun d'entre nous il y aura une
responsabilité
chacun d'entre nous aura à s'y engager
car chacun d'entre nous compte plus que
lui même
c'est ce qui fait
du peuple français
cette force singulière
que j'aime
si profondément si intensément et que je
suis si fier de servir à nouveau
m
des couples macron sur le champ de mars
la tour eiffel derrière eux et et un
discours d'une dizaine de minutes du du
président réélu donc qui s'est dit fier
de servir à nouveau la france qu'ils
aiment tant
la marseillaise est ce qu'on va écouter
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
au
chômage
quand
ça
à
l'enseignant
[Applaudissements]
allons nous entendre
les jours
rires
[Musique]
c
les
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
on entend des mots
revenu
sur ses paroles
[Musique]
selon
égorger nos fils au combat
auj
le citoyen
[Applaudissements]
marceau
oh
oui
[Musique]
si haut
voilà vous venez d'entendre cette
marseillaise chantée a cappella au champ
de mars devant les époux macron pour la
réélection des manuels mâcon qui vient
de prononcer son discours où il a
effectivement remercier les
abstentionnistes ceux qui ont fait
barrage à marine le pen tout en disant
écoutez la colère de ceux qui se sont
exprimées aussi pour l'extrême-droite je
ne suis pas le candidat d'un camp mais
de tout et de tous ce soir une grande
nation écologique c'est ce que veut le
président la république pour ce prochain
quinquennat l'égalité hommes-femmes le
travail et la création et surtout une
méthode refonder philippe ballard vous
avez entendu comme moi un discours de
rassemblement et une main tendue à vos
électeurs ça fait pour ses chansons vous
savez paroles et paroles et paroles
enfin voilà non mais c'est un discours
velits d'un deuxième tour fille mercy
gérard longuet moi j'ai retenu certaines
phrases il parle de bienveillance de
respect nul ne doit être laissé au bord
du chemin vive plus haut rang en france
voir si on travaille chez mckinsey
effectivement on peut peut-être être
très heureux en france il ya un problème
de pouvoir d'achat parce qu'on l'a
évacué rapidement en fait je réalisais
un sondage ifop dia - il en quoi c'est
avec 58% des français je vois mes 78%
des français disent il a échoué dans sa
politique en termes de pouvoir d'achat
51 il y à une agression gratuite toutes
les 40 secondes en france qu est il fait
pendant cinq ans en termes de politique
migratoire c'est un flot continu
l'équivalent de la ville de nice mais
l'argent n'est la victoire confie thomas
alors
peut-être le renfort d'une partie de la
france a soumis ce puisque d'après les
messages
de gens
continueront de faire ton choix aussi
longtemps que des menus mâcon mais faut
pas pleurer après sur le lait renversé
le mieux c'est
c'est toujours ainsi à tous c'est un peu
facile mais la défiance -
l'egypte et la borne et
respectueux enfin quand on voit le débat
non c'est l'arrogance et emmanuel macron
voilà alors on en revient à ces
législatives qui devraient aller mettre
un terme annie espagnol nash et un mode
répond sur l'arrogance est marrant c'est
de cesser revenu régulièrement depuis
nos fêtes depuis le débat d'entre deux
tours ce qu'est ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que marine le pen nous
donne des leçons de travail et
d'investissement mais elle n'a pas voté
la loi de programmation militaire elle
n'a pas voté la loi contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes
elle n'a pas voté le bouclier énergies
fossiles bloc le prix du gaz et qui
bloque le créneau que je te jure t non
mais vous ne l'avez pas voter c'est à
dire que vous prétendez défendre les
français au par une baisse de la tva
c'est beaucoup plus efficace doit
reconnaître que c'est qu'elle est au ban
du parlement et qu'elle défend ses
positions alors on n'a pas les mêmes
mais les défend mais vous n'y êtes un
chien on a sept députés ça vous a pas
échappé pourquoi pourquoi la
proportionnelle n'a pas été mis en place
alors je vais étonner mais c'était pas
la proportionnelle intégrale que nous
avait vendu et mnbaq
c'est une dose de proportionnelle au
niveau world et pourquoi la profonde
sagesse n'a pas subi en france et
l'espagne est député c'est bien certain
nombre de promesses qui vient d'être
viennent d'être faites la part emmanuel
macron comment être sûr que vous allez
réaliser ses promesses alors que vous
êtes au pouvoir depuis cinq ans et que
cette grande nation écologique ce
travail libéré aux énergies tout cela
vous ne m'aviez déjà promis il ya cinq
ans mais tout à fait d'abord je rappelle
que emmanuel macron a réalisé 75% de son
programme c'est ce que ressort des facs
check-in garde donc donc il avait
annoncé un certain nombre de choses il
les a faites il ya deux choses qui l'a
pas fait j'étais à des structures anti
les institutionnels la réforme
institutionnelle elle supposait d'avoir
la majorité va là-bas pensionnat
l'avions pas la proportionnelle la
restitution plus non parce que vous
savez que c'est une réforme de la
composition
du nombre de députés et c'est tout
l'ensemble qui permettait de refonder
nos institutions donc de déplorer c'est
la loi c'est la loi partout alors vous
avez raison je suis mis un terme à
l'annoncé la réforme de la constitution
le fait de ne pas avoir les deux le fait
de ne pas avoir souvenir de majorité est
là et la deuxième chose c'est la réforme
des retraites qui est effectivement
revient sur la table et pas dans la
forme caricaturale qui nous est expliqué
parce que marine le pen cachent les
choses puisque dans son système pour
avoir une retraite à plein à taux plein
il faut travailler 42 ans qui fait quand
vous démarrez à 23 ans et pardon mais
beaucoup de français démarrent à 23 ans
parce qu'ils ont il enchaîne des petits
boulots il n'arrive pas mais même sans
faire des études parce qu'il ne rentre
pas sur le même but remake et non mais y
cotisent bay cotisé suffisamment mais
pas suffisamment et donc ça vous fait
des efforts et du travail qu'un jour
vous êtes vous content car des
analyses qui ne vit que il y aura pas d
ballon messi mais vous faites du fact
checking du par de pauw défectueux non
mais vous
très mauvais français ça a été du entre
le premier et le deuxième tour ça a été
un tir de missile de fait qu news de
votre part tout à l'heure vous parliez
vous disiez marine le pen voulait
supprimer le droit d'asile fait j'ai pas
dit car si
l'europe si cause dont je remets pas en
cause on demandait tout simplement à ce
que les dossiers soient déposées dans
les consulats et les ambassades à
l'étranger parce que
ça vous a pas échappé que les tiers
c'est d'être déboutés du droit d'asile
seraient sur le thème
22 heures j'espère qu'ils
avaient peu de dispositions pratiques
mais un beau spectacle bon merci de
pour tenir aux côtés des soutiens des
manuels macron juste après le discours
du président de la république réélu pour
cinq ans
exactement le champ de mars qui commence
à se vider tout doucement le président
de la république réélu qui est arrivé un
petit peu après
21h30 il était accompagnée évidemment de
son épouse brigitte macron mais aussi
d'une trentaine d'enfants d'adolescents
ce sont les enfants des bénévoles de sa
campagne ou des membres de son équipe il
a donc parcouru les dizaines de mètres
depuis le pied de la tour eiffel jusqu'à
son pupitre il a été évidemment
ovationné sur le l'hymne à la joie
l'aude à la joie l'hymne européen
emmanuel macron qui a prononcé un
discours assez rapide en un peu plus
d'une dizaine de minutes il a salué
évidemment ceux qui avaient voté pour
lui ce qui avait fait sa campagne on
sait que lui a été un peu empêché il a
remercié les militants sur le terrain
mais il s'est également adressé à ceux
qui avaient voté pour lui uniquement
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite il
a eu un mot pour les abstentionnistes
mais aussi pour les électeurs de marine
le pen façon de dire que pour lui ce
soir il n'est plus le candidat d'un clan
mais bien le président de tous les
français il a voulu dire que son nouveau
mandat et bien ce ne serait pas une
continuité mais une réinvention voici ce
que le chef de l'état a promis ensuite
la foule s'est mise à chanter la
marseillaise évidemment et une mezzo
soprano égyptienne farah el dib annie a
entonné évidemment cette chanson la
marseillaise l'hymne français il ne
s'est pas attardé forcément très
longtemps même si je dois vous avouer je
vois plus très bien s'il est encore dans
la foule là les soutiens essaye
d'approcher j'imagine les mini son
équipe de campagne voire même le
président de la république mais
effectivement un sur son discours a duré
peu de temps c'est peut-être aussi une
manière de signifier que ça y est dès
maintenant il se remet au travail et
c'est que ce nouveau quinquennat il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'attentes
merci l amende un gamin en duplex donc
du champ de mars où le président de la
république vient de s'exprimer il est un
peu plus
de 22h ce soir bienvenue à ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur les chaînes
parlementaires
nous accueillons plateau nos experts
pour analyser et pour décrypter ce
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
de 2022 et bien sûr se projeter dans les
prochaines élections législatives
on va voir avec qui emmanuel macron va
gouverner qu'elle sera aussi le choix de
son premier ministre puis on vous
redonne les résultats les dernières
estimations pour être précis de nos
partenaires ipsos sopra et steria donc
le score évolue au fur et à mesure de la
soirée
58,8 % maintenant selon les dernières
estimations et
41,2 % pour marine le pen on vous
présente tout de suite nos invités
claire chartier bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste et essayiste
j'accueille également martial foucault
bonsoir directeur du centre de
recherches politiques de sciences pour
le cevipof erwan lecoeur bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes politologue
et sociologue spécialiste de l'extrême
droite et puberl pierre latry vous êtes
toujours avec nous de chez ipsos chef de
groupe notre partenaire pour cette
soirée et sopra et steria
revenons avec vous sur ses résultats
58,8 % pour le président de la
république est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
vote d'adhésion des français ou d'un
vote par défaut
majoritairement chez les électeurs des
manuels macron c'est un vote d'adhésion
mais il ya quand même plus de quatre
électeurs d'emmanuel macron sur 10 ans
42% qui ont voté pour lui pour faire
barrage à marine le pen donc c'est quand
même un élément très important
clairement ça change un petit peu ce
n'est pas un vote complètement
d'adhésion on voit là très clairement
qu'il ya un rejet avant tout de
l'extrême droite plus qu'une adhésion
pour un grand nombre d'électeurs alors
quelles sont les motivations peut-être
du vote par la suède c'est
de ce qu'ils veulent faire barrage à
marine le pen s'est clairement on l'a vu
notamment chez les électeurs de gauche à
l'idée que le fonds de front républicain
n'est pas encore tout à fait mort et
qu'il faut faire barrage à l'extrême
droite même si on n'a pas forcément
envie de voter pour emmanuel macron
alors qu'hier on va vous avez réalisé un
sondage on s'est vraiment appuyer dessus
dans cette soirée électorale et c'était
très intéressant c'était la veille donc
il y est et vous avez interrogé les
français sur les raisons de leur vote et
on va se projeter vers les législatives
si vous le voulez bien avec une question
je vais lire la question souhaitez vous
que les partis suivent en sortent
renforcées
affaiblis ou alors ni renforcé ni
affaibli à l'issue des élections
législatives de juin prochain qui
permettront d'élire des députés à
l'assemblée nationale qu est ce qui
ressort de ce cette question ce qui
ressort c'est qu'ils sont que la
tripartition à laquelle on assiste eh
bien les français souhaiteraient la voir
plus présentes à l'assemblée nationale
puisque les deux partis qu'ils
aimeraient voir le plus renforcé son la
france insoumise et le rassemblement
national et les deux partis qui
souhaitent avoir le plus affaibli sont
le parti socialiste et les républicains
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même ce
souhait de voir émerger plus de députés
insoumis et du rassemblement national
mais avec pour la république en marche
un petit score à la question souhaitez
vous que ce parti sort renforcée comme
la république en marge des tiens déjà la
majorité des sièges effectivement non on
peut souhaiter que ça reste dans la
situation actuelle alors quelles leçons
peut en tirer c'est il faut être prudent
avec un sondage comme celui-là parce que
c'est sont pas des intentions de vote
l'islate y va on est bien d'accord non
absolument on ne peut pas pour l'instant
faire de toute façon d'ascension d'autre
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'on ne
connaît pas les configurations
d'alliance qui va y avoir lors du
premier tour des législatives donc c'est
un petit peu difficile de mesurer ce
qu'on peut voir en revanche c'est qui
encore une fois ce souhait de voir
présents à l'assemblée bien des forces
politiques qui ont tout simplement
réalisé lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle des scores
très importants et donc c'est normal
aussi que quand marine le pen arrive
avec 24% et jeunes enfants avec 22% et
bien de voir des députés de ces deux
mouvements là présents à l'assemblée
mais ce que les électeurs souhaitent
donner une majorité à emmanuel macron eh
bien non
en tout cas la majorité 56% ne souhaite
pas qu emmanuel macron est une majorité
et un seau habitations qui excusa il ya
un souhait de cohabitation ce qui est
quand même important et il faut quand
même voir que sur les 44% restants qui
pensent qu'il faut qu emmanuel macron
est une majorité n'y en a que 20 % qui
le souhaitent 24% considèrent que c'est
ce qui aurait de mieux de toute façon
puisque maintenant qu'il a été réélu ben
autant qu'il ait une majorité c'est ce
qu'on retrouve notamment chez les
électeurs de yannick jadot et valérie
pécresse mais chez les autres on voit
clairement une volonté d'une
cohabitation et de battre emmanuel
macron lors des législatives
merci beaucoup pierre latry d'être nous
éclairer sur ses autres éléments qu'on
n'avait pas encore partager avec les
téléspectateurs de public sénat et de et
de lcp
je ne sais pas quel message vous venez
de me faire passer en régime c'est
emmanuel macron qui va donner c'est pour
ça qu'on dénie n'exprime pas une tu
entends mieux que l'autre alors il
manuel macron vous l'avez entendu qui
s'est exprimé il ya quelques instants va
ré écouter une partie du discours de
voeux du président réélu ce soir je sais
aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
et je veux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote mobilisent pour
les années à venir
je suis dépositaire
de leur sens du devoir
de leur attachement à la république et
du respect des différences qui se sont
exprimés ces dernières semaines
pierre chartier une réaction avec ce que
vous venez d'entendre ce que nous disait
pierre latry il ya tout juste quelques
instants est ce qu'il y à un vote de
barrage la qui a été fait contre les
électeurs de fin des électeurs de marine
le pen pour barrer la route à marine le
pen ou est ce qu'il y à un vote
d'adhésion pour vous au projet d'
emmanuel macron une envie des manières
mâcon dans ce pays alors je pense que la
réponse est certainement pas là à la 12e
deuxième idée que vous avez soulevé
c'est vraisemblablement emmanuel macron
a gagné mais c'est surtout marine le pen
qui a perdu ça c'est une évidence assez
absolue et d'ailleurs on vient d'en
avoir la démonstration à l'instant avec
votre intervenants qui quand même vient
de donner une information qui assez
majeur c'est qu'ils majorité de français
si j'ai bien entendu souhaite une
cohabitation qui s'exprime dans se sont
mariés quand même laissé la vie assez
énorme en soi donc c'est une victoire
par défaut bien sûr c'est une victoire
par défaut je pense que c'est aussi ça
montre qu'il aura fallu quand même 20
ans pour prendre la mesure de la recycle
configuration politique de la place
qu'occupe aujourd'hui les populismes
tant de droite que de gauche donc ce
n'est pas une france de bloc c'est une
france avec 3 blocs que là encore les
informations tombent dans d'avoir
reflète totalement ça c'est à dire et
aussi je dirais la le manque de lucidité
d'une classe politique qui me semblent
n'a pas du tout pris la mesure et une
faim de manière n'a pas voulu voir ce
qui se jouait pop donc on se retrouve
dans une situation qui va être
extrêmement compliqué enfin si une
majorité de français est pour une
cohabitation imaginer le pataquès que ça
va donner quand même avec un enjeu
évidemment majeur autour de ces
élections législatives bajard à montréal
bonsoir soir vous accueille avec plaisir
maître de conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii docteur en
sciences politiques
si si on analyse
les prises de parole de cette soirée
c'est totalement inédit dans l'histoire
de la vème république sert la tonalité
voyez ce que je veux dire dans dans la
façon dont les oppositions se sont
exprimés quelques minutes à peine après
une élection qui est quand même une
élection
puissante malgré tout deux des manuels
macron avec nos dernières estimations
ces 58 8% des voix en effet parce que
les oppositions font le pari qu'il y
aura un troisième tour que ce troisième
tour ils soient sociales ou qu'ils
soient les législatives plus
probablement les législatives
aujourd'hui ou considérer dans
l'opposition enfin l'opposition
considère que cette élection était une
forme de d'élection par défaut et
qu'elle doit être en jambes et pour
lancer la bataille des législatives ces
législatives on est très particulière
d'abord parce que depuis le début du
quinquennat c'est la première fois qu'on
aura une majorité reconduite avec son
président la seule majorité qui a été
reconduite c'était en 2007 ont changé de
président pas cette chirac à sarkozy et
donc ça changeait la donne le deuxième
élément c'est qu'on a deux mois un temps
de latence important or on dit souvent
que les français veulent donner une
majorité au président de la république
en fait c'est pas vrai en fait vous avez
une démobilisation de l'électorat de
position qui est groggy par sa défaite
après les présidentielles et une
mobilisation de l'électorat
présidentielle là pour le coup c'est
l'inversé en train de se passer alors
c'est possible premièrement et dans
l'appel des leaders par exactement il ya
une volonté aujourd'hui de mobiliser ce
que ça marcherait ce que ça marchera pas
pour l'instant c'est très très difficile
à dire en revanche il ya malgré tout
avec ce temps de latence la possibilité
que de nouvelles problématiques s'impose
en termes de pouvoir d'achat etc et que
cet électorat qui d'habitude est groggy
et bien se ressaisisse le troisième
élément c'est qu'on a une majorité qui
tue majorité sortante qui est très mal
implanté d'abord parce qu'une partie des
députés vient grande partie nulle part
et ensuite parce qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui la fin du cumul des mandats
on l'avait déjà connu en 2017 mais
malgré tout c'est et des députés qui
jadis et bien avait été implanté et on a
vu le résultat par ailleurs sur les
anciennes majorité donc là on a quand
même des incertitudes est ce que ces
incertitudes mèneront à une surprise
peut-être peut-être pas mais c'est le
pari d'opposition et c'est paris des
discours de l'opposition ce soir martial
foucault pour éclairer bien comprendre
le sondage aussi qui vient d'être donné
ce soir est-ce que ça préfigure
véritablement de la nouvelle assemblée
nationale qu on pourrait avoir au mois
de juin sachant que c'est un scrutin qui
ne bénéficient pas généralement au
rassemblement national oui non je crois
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent
parce que bien sûr c'est la logique de
parler des élections initiatives d'aidé
ce soir mais bon on ne connaît quasiment
aucun des candidats investis par toutes
les formations politiques on est encore
très loin des logiques d'alliance qui
pourraient se nouer on a entendu l'appel
ce soir d'eric zemmour à l'union des
droites nationales et pas et pas au fond
des droites extrêmes on a entendu jean
luc mélenchon indiqué qu'il il fallait
discuter sur des alliances quand je vois
le vote jean luc mélenchon au soir du
premier tour je me dis que la question
des alliances ne va pas être simple je
pense qu'on souhaiterait tous pouvoir
écouter la teneur des discussions des
alliances avec europe ecologie les verts
le parti socialiste et le parti
communiste français ensuite
institutionnellement
il est vrai que ce besoin de
cohabitation ou 7e se souhaite
cohabitation des français se heurte
aussi à un principe des règles du jeu
électoral le mode de scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours si on est sur
une tripartition c'est pas la même chose
que si on est sur un système bipartite
ou là effectivement la cohabitation
prend tout son sens donner un
contre-pouvoir à eux au camp qui a perdu
l'élection présidentielle et je rappelle
un point qui est quand même fondamental
le minimum requis pour accéder au second
tour d'une élection juste at il ses 12
points 5 500 les inscrits inscrit donc
en fonction de l'abstention vous voyez
que s'il n'y a pas d'alliance dans les
gauches ou dans les droites finalement
ça peut être un vrai boulevard pour la
majorité sortante élargi peut-être au
renfort d'horizon des loire philippe
modem c'est déjà acté et peut-être
peut-être qu'un certain nombre de
députés et l'air sortant préférons avoir
la pancarte de la majorité
présidentielle plutôt que le logo et
l'air pour faire campagne et donc vous
pouvez voir aussi une recomposition est
large à marans voilée au centre autour
de la majorité les semaines à venir
particulièrement passionnante erwan
lecoeur cette phrase d'eric zemmour qui
nous a certainement pas échappé dans son
discours huit fois que la défaite frappe
le nom de le pen il ya beaucoup de
paradoxes a analysé dans cette soirée
est le paradoxe de la victoire
d'emmanuel macron qui est le premier
président il réellement pouvoir être élu
mais qui fait face à une opposition plus
forte que jamais et puis aussi le
paradoxe marine le pen qui fait un score
le plus élevé de l'histoire de l'extrême
droite en france et qui pour autant
effectivement il ya sept
7 défaites
élection après élection
génération après génération qui frappe
le camp où le clan le pen c'est tout le
problème avec cette élégance cette
élection et cette campagne qui en gros
pour nous sortir de notre marasme que ça
faisait deux ans qu'on savait que macron
le pen serait second tour donc on a
s'est fait très peur avec eric zemmour
on s'est fait très peur avec marine le
pen soir du premier tour qui était quand
même à 48,50 2 dans pas mal d'instituts
donc en effet marine le pen fait une
performance historique non négligeable
le lepénisme réussi au second tour
d'abord à être normalisées comme
candidate de second tour et c'est quand
même une performance non négligeable
ça existe à peu près nulle part ailleurs
normalisée c'est-à-dire que désormais
elle est la candidate qui sera face au
candidat du entre guillemets système au
deuxième tour deuxième chose donc
historiquement il ya clairement une
progression absolue très forte qui fait
aussi que la question maintenant c'est
quand quand est-ce que cette famille
politique prendra le pouvoir si vous
venez dans la phrase d'eric zemmour il
ya il prononce pas plafond de verre mais
elle elle est là prête évidemment pour
eric zemmour comme pour bruno mégret en
son temps la question c'est bon
maintenant qu'elle a perdu comme j'avais
dit qu'elle allait perdre est ce que oui
ou non on peut revenir sur la séquence
juste avant c'est à dire celle ou moins
j'avais enfin j'avais les médias qui qui
parlait que de moi il n'a fait que sept
pour cent au jour d'aujourd'hui ni lui
ni marion maréchal n'aurait pu faire le
score de marine marine le pen tout le
monde le sait ou presque
le populisme s'est imposée en grande
bretagne s'est imposée aux etats-unis
est-ce qu'il peut gagner en france vous
corps lui dire exe mot pas une paille ne
gagnera jamais oui mais quel populisme
celui d'eric zemmour pas aujourd'hui
pour l'instant eric zemmour est dans une
niche il est dans ce qu'on appelle
l'extrême droite avec des gens plutôt
bourgeois plutôt bien sur eux mêmes et
c'est inné il est incapable de parler
aux gens du nord pas de calais au calme
marine le pen a parlé depuis et son père
mais surtout elle depuis une vingtaine
d'années dont on parle bien là il
faudrait pas penser que les trois blocs
les trois pôles en réalité à mon sens en
termes sociologiques et politiques des
trois pôles qui ne sont pas des partis
c'est bien leur problématique ils ne
sont pas des partis et donc aux
législatives pour l'instant comme ça
vient d'être dit ils sont incapables de
s'allier en autant de parties il n'y a
pas un seul à seul de ses trois pôles
sauf peut-être celui de emmanuel macron
parce que les faits en effet 2 j'ai
gagné la présidentielle ralliez vous à
mon panache blanc ça ça peut encore
fonctionner comme en 2017 mais pour les
deux autres que ce soit la
social-écologie sur notre gauche ou le
camp radi de droite et le populiste
nationaliste sur notre droite ces deux
camps sont des mouvements ne sont pas
des partis ils ont un leader ils n'ont
pas de terrain ils n'ont pas d'élus sur
le terrain c'est quand la non pas les
lucioles donc on est dans une double
injonction difficile pour les
législatives et au sortir de cette
présidentielle oui marine le pen a fait
un très bon score non elle n'a pas fait
l'accident électorale qu'elle aurait pu
espérer faire comme trump comme le grès
dit etc elle ne l'a pas fait parce qu'
il reste un réflexe dans cette dans ce
pays un réflexe eu plus de paul plus de
front républicain mais un réflexe
républicain quand même et puis il y
avait aussi ré et puis maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que ces trois
pôles qui sont clairement j'ai envie de
jeu versité gramsci comme je lé fais sur
ce plateau il ya quelques semaines
gramsci disait le vieux monde se meurt
le nouveau peine à émerger et entre les
deux naissent des monstres déjà des
montres nous sommes dans l'antre 2 le
vieux paul c'était les deux parties qui
organisait la vie politique le nouveau
on sait bien qu'on va vers une tripoli
est pratiquement polarisation mais on
n'y arrive pas les français ils sont
prêts et c'est pour ça qu'ils demandent
une entre guillemets une
ils ne veulent pas donner tout le
pouvoir un maquereau parce qu'ils
pensent qu emmanuel macron ne représente
pas de majorité dans ce pays et ils
n'ont pas tort et donc ils veulent que
macron je gère avec quelqu'un d'autre et
la question qui va se poser au soir des
législatives et des nombreuses
triangulaires potentiel si jamais les
trois pôles arrive à se constituer ce
sera alors nombreuses c'est pas évident
évident avec les 12 demi pour cent des
inscrits on peut se retrouver beaucoup
de villes annonce alors je me priorité
au direct phares dont je reprends la
main tam traduit et avec laurent la
comédie pour le rassemblement national
oui l'aurore jacques laurent jacobellis
tout d'abord et bien votre réaction à
ces propos d'emmanuel macro 1 qui estime
que ce vote l'obligent qu'il a pu pour
lui un vote barrage au rassemblement
national c'est bien la preuve que le
front républicain n'est pas mort oh la
la effectivement nous avions en face de
nous tous ces vieux parti qui
s'accrochaient un peu alors fromage de
l'extrême gauche à la droite et qui ont
voté pour emmanuel macron faisant une
espèce de majorité improbable sans
projet commun nous verrons bien ce que
fait manuel matheron il ya fort à parier
malheureusement qu'il continuera dans la
casse sociale dans les frontières
ouvertes à tous vents et dans ce mépris
permanent des français deux cas il ya un
message d'espoir avec 42% marine le pen
avec jean natte bardella d'ailleurs
incarne cette grande force populaire
d'opposition la seule d'ailleurs
probablement puisque jean mais jean-luc
mélenchon a appelé à voter pour emmanuel
macron cette force d'opposition qui
serait capable aux législatives d'amener
des députés qui ne laisseront pas les
pleins pouvoirs à emmanuel macron parce
que sinon ce sera un quinquennat encore
plus violent encore plus dur que celui
que nous venons subir on entend que vous
dites donc jean luc mélenchon et du côté
des manuels macro car il a appelé à ne
pas voter pour votre candidate il s'est
exprimé hier jean luc mélenchon ce soir
justement pour demander aux français de
voter pour lui aux législatives au
contraire et bien pour devenir premier
ministre pour avoir une forme de
cohabitation avec emmanuel macron parce
que qu'est ce que ça vous inspire quelle
drôle d'opposants qui rêve d'être le
premier ministre d'emmanuel macro après
avoir voté à appeler à voter pour lui
non jean luc mélenchon est un rabatteur
il rabat les voix des bobos des centres
urbains et des banlieues communautariser
verts emmanuel macron c'est le petit
soldat d'emmanuel macro je pense qu'il
est disqualifiée pour représenter une
force d'opposition au président de la
république on a également entendu ce
soir eric zemmour qui a souligné votre
défaite je le cite sommes nous condamnés
à perdre il demande lui dans l'union
nationale pour les législatives il
demande une coalition des droites et des
patriotes avec et bien reconquête le
rassemblement national est debout la
france
pourquoi vous y refusez-vous puisqu'il
ya déjà eu des réponses simples pour
dire que vous refusiez une coalition de
partis à partie oui je crois que les
français ces accords d'appareil n'y
crois plus un nom il y aura 577
candidats du rassemblement national ou
soutenu par le rassemblement national
parce que clairement les français nous
ont demandé de porter de mener cette
opposition et c'est autour de nos
candidats que devra faire ce
rassemblement de tous les patriotes d'où
qu'ils viennent vous disiez de droite
mais je dirais aussi de gauche parce
qu'il ya des gens de gauche pour la
france au coeur et qui ne peuvent pas se
résoudre à la politique d' emmanuel
macron mais clairement ce soir marine le
pen et jordan bardella sont à la tête de
la plus grande force d'opposition a bien
c'est autour de nous que devra se faire
la recomposition demain dernière
question parce que tout de même l'écart
est plus important que ce qui avait été
anticipé alors qu'est ce qui a posé
problème comme qu'est ce qui a péché
pour votre candidat écoutez nous ferons
l'analyse des résultats dans le détail
évidemment dans les jours qui viennent
mais vous savez quand il ya une
quinzaine de partis politiques qui
appellent à voter pour emmanuel macron
quand je crois la presse a fait montre
d'un parti pris comme on n'en
connaissait pas qu'on en n'avait jamais
connu et bien faire 42 % c'est un
exploit en tout cas c'est un exploit
historique pour nous et une fois encore
nous avons compris que les français nous
demandaient de les protéger dans
l'opposition contre la triste politique
d' emmanuel macron c'est ce que nous
ferons
donc le rassemblement national qui voit
donc une victoire dans cette défaite qui
lance donc la bataille des législatives
merci à mme tran huy vous étiez avec
laurent jacobellis qui appelle
effectivement à construire une force
d'opposition rassemblement national aux
prochaines législatives du mois de juin
c'est aussi ce que proposait jean luc
mélenchon dans son discours juste après
les résultats de ce second tour on
écoute le leader de la france a soumis
le troisième tour comment ce soir les 12
et 19 juin au lieu les élections
législatives
vous pouvez pas trop monsieur macron et
choisir un autre chemin
le 12 et 19 juin un autre monde est
encore possible si vous élisez une
majorité je dis bien majorité de députés
de la nouvelle union populaire qui doit
s'élargir
le bloc populaire qui s'est constituée
autour de ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
est dans ce pays
dorénavant le tiers état qui peut tout
changer s'il se rassemblent et s'il sait
la rue
cler chartier jean luc mélenchon at il
une chance même une toute petite chance
de réussir ce pari alors moi je voulais
juste revenir un instant quand même sur
mon avis ce qui me semble clé dans cette
cette élection ccc le populisme qu'est
ce que ça veut dire parce que je pense
que marine le pen on vient d'en parler
elle incarne à un néo peu plus doucement
quand elle a réussi à faire quelque
chose que n'a pas fait jean luc
mélenchon c'est à dire qu'elle est là
mais longer
le facteur social qui pas du tout
remarqué lors d'entraînements avec le
facteur identitaire qui lui est un
marqueur d'extrêmement donc on a une
hybridation chez marine le pen donc
marine le pen le rn que nous n'avons pas
chez jean luc mélenchon et qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que le
populisme c'est tellement bien installé
il a tellement évolué et qu'aujourd'hui
ils posent effectivement une question
majeure au reste de la classe politique
à mon sens il reflète
ce qui c'est ce qui a muté dans la dans
la population dans la c'est à dire qu'il
a il reflète le mondial il apporte une
forme de réponse à toute une partie des
français qui se sentent méprisés entre
avait d'ailleurs le terme mépris et très
souvent évoquée par le n et cette
question là elle n'est pas anodine parce
que dans une société qui finalement
s'est recentré sur les individus qui
bénéficient de canaux d'interpellations
direct avec le politique qui n'existait
pas auparavant
dans laquelle les citoyens estime ont
pris le goût de parler en leur nom donc
se mettent à a contesté le fait même de
déléguer leurs représentations donc
c'est quand même aussi une évolution
majeure
d'une certaine manière c'est un peu
rousseau qui a gagné contre voltaire en
quelque sorte ronseaux c'était vraiment
le peuple citoyen de shadows voltaire
incarnant un peu l'élite finalement
quelque chose qui à l'origine de
l'histoire française politique est en
train de se rejouer là et c'est cette
question que pose cette élection est on
ce sera évidemment l'un des défis et
macron d'inventer des ddd mode de
gouvernance démocratique on peut dire on
va dire ça comme ça pour répondre en
partie mais je vais je suis un peu têtu
je vais quand même posé la question
mélenchon parce que j'aimerais bien
qu'on soit sur ce je vais mélenchon dans
quelques minutes quelles sont ses forces
parce que moi je vois pour l'instant
peut-être plus de faiblesse par rapport
à cet objectif de devenir premier
ministre qui nous a un peu tout se fait
ricaner on va être on va être très
honnête quelles sont ses forces pour y
arriver a déjà effectivement on voit
davantage ses faiblesses il déjà pas
beaucoup d'élus députés au précédent
quinquennat là toutes les îles à il
s'est très vite d aider des tractations
se sont quand même été lancé la gauche
de façon assez unanime est prête à
l'étang dans la malle mais la gauche est
effectivement dans un état véritablement
lamentable cette fois-ci peut-être
davantage encore qu'il ya cinq ans quand
même donc cette opportunité qui se
présente elle est à mon sens nouvelle
c'est à dire que certains peuvent se
dire effectivement jean luc mélenchon
c'est vraiment peu ce qui reste de la
gauche c'est peut-être pas toute la
gauche que l'on aime enfin c'est ce qui
reste de la gauche donc on va y aller
parce que c'est la seule façon
finalement de promouvoir une partie de
nos idées donc il y à là peut-être un
espace pour lui
benjamin parce qu'il ya cette première
force d'opposition on est à la recherche
cette première force là qui va se
dessiner au mois de juin est-ce que
l'alliance qui semble quand même se
profiler à gauche peut-être pas avec le
parti socialiste mais avec les
écologistes avec le parti communiste
même jean-luc mélenchon et intérêts
finalement oui évidemment il ya
particulièrement intérêt parce que les
législatives sont des élections un peu
hybride vous avez un élément locales
malgré tout et donc quand vous avez un
député ps qui est implanté vous avez
plutôt intérêt à le soutenir ou en tout
cas à passer un accord avec l'appareil
au niveau local il faut pas croire que
ces élections vont se jouer comme les
élections nationales vous avez une prime
aux sortants vous avez une prime à
l'implantation qui peut malgré tout
jouer et par ailleurs comme ça a été dit
si jamais vous voulez avoir une chance
de l'emporter dans une circonscription
au vu du mode de scrutin eh bien il faut
que votre camp politique soit
relativement unis parce que jean luc
mélenchon par avec quand même deux
handicaps majeurs le premier handicap
c'est que l'électorat et les filles est
un électorat relativement
abstentionnistes l'électorat et les
filles de jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour de la présidentielle est un
électorat composite vous avez un le
parti de vote utile dans les
centre-villes vote utile finalement
c'est pas évident qu'il ya un effet vote
utile est donc l'électorat mobilisables
c'est pas forcément l'électorat qui
votent et les fit donc c'est un
électorat à ces abstentionnistes arriver
à le mobiliser sur une élection
intermédiaire ça marche assez mal
souvenez-vous des européennes
souvenez-vous des municipales et c est
le deuxième élément c'est que le mode de
scrutin favorise les partis les plus
centristes si vous retrouvez face à la
gauche et bien le droit de vote pour
vous si vous retrouvez face à la droite
la gauche votent pour vous et donc à
partir de là quand vous êtes un parti
très polarisé la fille le rn et bien
vous êtes dans une situation très très
compliqué il faut trianguler au centre
et ça vous ne le faites pas son temps de
la main à eux élevés waro pc et marcel
foulhoux ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on avait vu alors ça c'était une
leçon du premier tout l'extrême
volatilité d'une partie de l'électorat
qui s'étaient portés vers jean luc
mélenchon dans les toutes dernières
heures dans les 24 48 48 heures et qui
vont pas forcément voter pour des
députés
la france insoumise dans dans sept ou
neuf semaines oui non il faut il faut
être très prudent parce que on a quand
même des quelques références historiques
1993 élections législatives avec on a vu
arriver moi ce que j'appelais à l'époque
les accidentés du suffrage universel et
un grand nombre de députés qui étaient
candidats pour la première fois face à
des députés notamment socialistes
parfaitement implanté et on est vu alors
cette occasion l'a découvert que l'usure
du pouvoir faisait que les électeurs
avaient envie bien avant 2017 où on a
commencé à parler du terme de dégage
isme déjà pratiqué cette modalité de
remplacement des députés et 2017 même
chose des députés socialistes très bien
implanté mais dont on considérer qu'ils
avaient contribué par soit un soutien la
politique de françois hollande soit de
l'autre côté dans la fronde qui qui
n'avait plus la légitimité pour être
représentants au parlement donc pour
cette élection ce qui ce qui vient
d'être dit est juste c'est à dire que
c'est un mode de scrutin qui
effectivement favorise en cas de
triangulaire plutôt le candidat
les candidats du sens mais toute la
logique c'est ce qu'on vient d'évoquer à
l'instant c'est que vous n'avez plus
nécessairement un parti ce sera pas
forcément un candidat et les filles mais
le candidat
tenu par l'union populaire et donc là
vous brouiller totalement la carte pour
les électeurs ils ne soutiendront pas un
candidat ou une candidate et les filles
mais un candidat qui verra peut être un
suppléant europe ecologie les verts mme
ou bien un versement suppléant et les
filles et même chose d'assumé ça suppose
de parvenir à ces accords avec avec les
six autres partis politiques je pense
qu'on n'aura pas un accord national et
qui verra dans les 577 des
circonscriptions des candidats un seul
candidat au nom de l'union populaire
vraiment là pour le coup la géographie
électorale est extrêmement riche
d'enseignements et on verra de toute
façon les investitures et les filles se
feront au gré des résultats à l'élection
présidentielle on voit qu'il ya une
grande partie du sud ouest de la france
où la france insoumise et très pardon
louis la france a soumise est très en
retrait donc là il faudra s'appuyer sur
le parti socialiste
même le parti radical de gauche encore
dans dans ce territoire et inversement
dans le sens bretagne eh bien on verra
peut-être davantage ici l'union
populaire sans sans coup férir faire
faire alliance pour disputer cette
élection je rajoute un tout dernier
point sur le demande de que la demande
de cohabitation on l'avait déjà observée
avec les élections intermédiaires
régionales départementales ce ce souhait
des français d'avoir un contre-pouvoir
au plan local pour l'élection
l'initiative cette demande de
cohabitation c'est ce n'est au fond
qu'une demande de réhabilitation du rôle
du parlement et qui a été quand même mis
un peu sous cloche depuis non pas cinq
ans mais gérée depuis 2007 avec nicolas
sarkozy et d'une certaine manière ce qui
va être un peu le juge de paix c'est le
niveau de participation on s'attend à
des à des scores autour de 40 45 % de
taux de participation à cette élection
initiative vous voyez les résultats vont
être profondément dépendant de la
mobilisation des électeurs donc si vous
avez trois blocs quel sera le bloc qui
aura cette capacité à mobiliser est-ce
que la république en marche va faire
campagne pour cette élection initiative
est ce que c'est une campagne portée
nationalement ou bien est ce que ce sont
les comités locaux dans marche qui vont
peut-être se réveiller au revoir le jour
et faire campagne c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment l'interrogation autant on peut
dire que l efi eren qu'on fait campagne
pendant cette élection présidentielle
sur des territoires différents mais
l'enjeu ça va être comment mobiliser un
électorat qui d'une manière générale on
le voit en tendance historique depuis 40
ans est le seul mais voter l'arrêt
l'élan d'une campagne présidentielle qui
avec avait du souffle puisque par
définition est belle macro et la vue est
entrée en campagne très tardivement
absolument et donc ça aura un impact sur
les vies des 58
pour deux raisons à la fois parce qu'il
n'y a plus l'effet de surprise est donc
il ya effectivement un grand nombre de
députés sortants le même si on estime à
30 à 40 le nombre de députés de la
république en marche qui ne souhaite pas
poursuivre leur aventure parlementaire
donc il ya un profond renouvellement et
on sait bien c'est cette notion de
momentum d'une dynamique d'une élection
présidentielle à une option initiative
joue mais encore faut-il la mettre à
l'oeuvre et c'est là ça passe par faire
campagne je sais bien que le terme faire
campagne peut paraître désuet
aujourd'hui dans cette décomposition des
partis politiques mais mobilisé un
électeur simplement en espérant qu'il
sera exposée à des signaux médiatique
comme vous disiez nouveau et qui sont de
plus en plus d individualiser ça reste
un pari extrêmement audacieux et et
cette fois ci il y a beaucoup de temps
entre l'élection présidentielle et
l'élection législative cette semaine
cette semaine pour faire campagne avec
des thèmes qui sont parfois difficiles à
défendre comme la retraite à 65 ans et
puis un possible dérapage on se
souviendra à la tva sociale de
jean-louis borloo on avait dit que ça
avait coûté
des électeurs et l'air est ce qui peut
se passer beaucoup de choses
effectivement pour la majorité sortante
faut quand même pas oublier bon
l'abstention on en a beaucoup parlé et
dans l'abstention moi ce qui me semble
particulièrement intéressant c'est que
la majorité ce qui forme le coeur de
l'abstention c'est pas le lentilles
système en fait c'est l'abstention
d'indifférence et l'abstention de la
différence ça veut quand même dire
beaucoup alors non seulement dans ces
élections législatives normalement votre
nom mais en plus quand vous tenez ça en
compte ça veut dire que ce n'est plus
donc le ca n'est plus simplement con air
le non consentement à aux mécanismes de
la démocratie libérale telle qu'on
connaît c'est à dire donc je consens a
donc voté pour quelqu'un qui va qui
n'est pas moi qui va me représenter ça
va plus loin que ça veut dire parce que
quand vous êtes dans le non consentement
l'autre existe encore là c'est même pas
ça c'est que en fait ça ne m'intéresse
plus sage et moi je fais un peu le
parallèle j'ai beaucoup suivi l'église
catholique est en fait ce qui s'est
passé avec l'église catholique c'est
pareil il faut c'est à dire que il ya eu
à certains moments sorte d'aversion de
roger puis il arrive un moment où en
fait on s'en fiche alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a on a le
sondage l'étude ipsos se prosterna sur
les principales raisons de l'abstention
qu'on va pouvoir découvrir ensemble la
question posée c'est parmi les raisons
suivantes quels sont les deux qui
explique le mieux pourquoi vous
envisagez de ne pas voter lors du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle voilà
la question qui a été posée je vous le
rappelle c'était à la veille du scrutin
aucun candidat ne correspond à vos idées
c'est ce qu'ils avaient en tête 35%
ensuite j'en ai assez de devoir aller
voter uniquement pour faire barrage les
jeux sont déjà faits il n'y a pas de
suspense sur le vainqueur je refuse de
choisir entre deux candidats que je
rejette totalement voilà les les quatre
les quatre premier item on peut
continuer
ensuite on a 10% cette élection n'aura
pas d'impact sur ma vie sur la situation
du pays je ne m'intéresse pas l'appui
thing maire gérald 10 et je ne suis pas
disponible le jour du vote voilà comment
comment on éclaire les raisons de
l'abstention va retourner au champ de
mars et voilà on fait vivre aussi le
direct et et l'ambiance dans le camp
d'emmanuel macron avec avec elsa monde
un gavage crois que le président réélu
est toujours sur place elle la
wii s'est offert un très très très très
long bain de foule un emmanuel macron
qui n'a pas ménagé son plaisir de saluer
bien ses supporters ses équipes
effectivement alors que vous voyez
derrière moi et bien on a plutôt plier
bagages un certains militants se
prennent en photo sur le pupitre
immortalise un peu ce moment c'est vrai
que la scénographie est assez
impressionnante avec cette tour eiffel
juste derrière et puis on retiendra
évidemment l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron
avec sa femme brigitte macron sur l'ode
à la joie accompagnés d'enfants
d'adolescents signe qu'il veut aussi
placé ce nouveau quinquennat pour la
jeunesse on retiendra aussi dans son
discours est bien une forme de
reconnaissance et que son élection
évidemment il ya une majorité des
français qui a voté pour lui mais
certains l'ont fait uniquement pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite
d'autres se sont abstenus d'autres ont
voté pour marine le pen emmanuel macron
a promis de rassembler tous les français
il a également promis et c'est une
promesse comment en forme de slogan cinq
ans de mieux voilà rien que ça c'est le
nouveau programme donc du chef de l'état
qui s'est dit aujourd'hui plus le
candidat d'un clan mais bien le
président de tous les français emmanuel
macron donc réélu assez confortablement
ce soir et qui a choisi ce champ de mars
pour fêter sa victoire avec derrière et
bien le monument le plus connu au monde
on va être un peu chauvin la tour eiffel
merci à mon gamin en direct de la tour
eiffel et du champ de mars ce soir où
emmanuel macron est venu fêter sa
victoire ou en tout cas prononcé un
discours erwan lecoeur
un discours de rassemblement ce soir je
ne suis pas le président d'un camp mais
le président de tous et de toutes a dit
le président de la république il faut
rassembler et on a une france très
fracturée on voit des alliances qui se
dessine à droite et à l'extrême rennes
forme d'union des droite à gauche
également est-ce qu'il faut une sorte
d'accord de gouvernement avant les
législatives entre les possibles alliés
les possibles mâcon compatibles je
dirais même que c'est là que ça va se
jouer énormément les législatives vont
beaucoup se jouer encore une fois avant
les législatives en fonction de ce que
va faire le nouveau président ou plus
exactement le président réélu vous
l'avez tous noté c'est le seul à part
françois mitterrand au sortir d'une
cohabitation et donc il ya une attente
d'une forme de cohabitation dans le pays
c'est là dessus que jean luc mélenchon
ou marine le pen vont essayer de jouer
c'est fait en sorte qu'ils soient
obligés de cohabiter avec nous soit l'un
soit l'autre emmanuel macron il a
plusieurs atouts dans sa main d'abord il
tient le temps il tient à l'horloge
pendant un mois et demi qui viennent il
va être le président il va mettre en
place un gouvernement s'il ya du neuf on
va le commenter médiatiquement c'est là
que ça va se jouer deuxième chose il
sait aussi qu'on l'a dit les
législatives l'abstention est très forte
beaucoup plus forte encore que la
présidentielle est l'abstention va
toucher principalement les catégories
populaires pas de chance c'est
exactement les électeurs et de mélenchon
et de marine le pen à 1017 moins d'un
français sur deux s'était déplacé viande
pour les légistes donc emmanuel macron
était sorti on le disait en blaguant
même une chèvre avec le logo m aurait
été élu ce ne sera plus le cas cette
fois parce que c'est le petit handicap
d'emmanuel macron il a cinq ans de vol
derrière lui et donc beaucoup de
mécontents de son de son quinquennat
vont quand même se mobiliser contre lui
et je la sors dans un instant parce que
la démonstration je connais vos
raisonnements va prendre un peu plus de
temps mais priorité au direct
à nos invités en duplex et françois
patriat le sénateur et les oem de la
côte-d'or président du groupe des pays
acp au sénat qui est avec elsa
et fidèle parmi les fidèles vous avez vu
chef de l'état quelques minutes après
les résultats dans quel état d'esprit
est il soulagé g écoutez j'étais à
l'elysée m'avait fait la gentillesse de
m'inviter pour 20 heures pour être là
quand les résultats tomberait j'avoue
pour moi c'était un moment d'émotion
supplémentaires mais cette fois ci la
dernière fois c'était un grand bonheur
cette fois ci c'est un grand bonheur
plus un soulagement parce que j'ai vu un
président qui est lui-même à mesurer le
chemin parcouru et déjà envisage de
chemin à parcourir donc ça veut dire
qu'il y avait il y avait dans son regard
dans ses propos à la fois bien sûr un
sentiment de bonheur mais aussi un
sentiment de gravité face à tous les
défis qui attendent maintenant demain
donc c'était un moment privilégié avec
leslie plus proches ses plus proches
autour de lui avec les équipes de
l'elysée qui travaillait avec lui et
d'avoir vécu ça à la salle des fêtes
avec avec tous tous les collaborateurs
proches il y avait quelques intimes du
président c'était pour moi un moment
vraiment d'émotion parce que ça fait
sept ans que je me suis engagé derrière
emmanuel macron depuis le masne mars
2015 où j'ai compris que que ce ce
responsable politique ce ministre à
l'époque avait une vraie vision pour le
pays qu'il en mesurer les défis qui
n'ouvrait des pistes jamais je
n'imaginerais que ça pourrait s'ouvrir
pour 12 ans alors bonheur soulagement
gravité mais aussi obligation il l'a dit
dans son discours ce résultat m'oblige
puisqu'il sait qu'une partie des
français qui ont voté pour lui l'ont
fait pour faire barrage et parce qu'il
sait qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de français
qui n'ont pas voté pour lui alors il ya
ceux qui ont voté pour lui non pas parce
qu'ils sont trop marron qui sont ma
chronique pas du tout qu'ils partagent
même pas ses idées ni son projet elle
l'a rappelé il ya ceux comme moi qui ont
voté parce qu'ils pensent que c'est le
meilleur le meilleur pour la france je
veux dire le meilleur 10 sa
responsabilité de main présidentielle
bien entendu le meilleur candidat et
puis à ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour lui
qui ce soir bien sûr se sentent frustrés
pour les colères ne sont pas apaisées je
crois que maintenant une fois le
lections retombée il faut prendre le
temps dans les jours qui viennent pour
parler aux français c'est à dire
des défis que nous avons à remonter
ensemble des voies qu'il faut emprunter
il a bien redit ce soir ce mandat ne
sera pas le même que le précédent ce
sera celui de la co-construction je veux
faire des réformes mais je vais les
faire avec tous les français y compris
ceux qu'on peut a voté pour moi du tout
et ceux qui aujourd'hui lui même
combattu essayons de faire ensemble de
faire entendre par de la pédagogie par
de la proximité par de la construction
faire ensemble on puisse réussir parce
qu'il faut vraiment que la france
réussisse moi j'ai entendu des discours
beaucoup déclinistes passéiste pendant
cette campagne qui qui donnait du
pessimisme français je crois que le
discours de ce soir de le président de
la république c'est un discours
d'optimisme redonner de l'optimisme aux
français l'esprit d'entreprendre pour
tous avec plus d'égalité plus de mesures
encore de proximité que les français
attendent et ça va être ça le lourd nord
peu tâche qui nous attend merci beaucoup
françois patriat on vous la vie rappelez
vous étiez là au début et vous êtes là
pour la réélection il a bien du chef de
l'état pour marche
avec donc françois patriat sénateur et
les mêmes de la côte d'ans martial
foucault on a entendu françois patriat
qui parlait d'une nouvelle méthode le
président emmanuel macron a également
parlé d'une méthode refonder pour ce
quinquennat on vient de le dire il a
exercé quand même cinq ans le pouvoir
est ce qu'on peut croire au j'ai changé
finalement de nicolas sarkozy en son
temps est-ce que emmanuel macron peut
réellement changé sa façon de gouverner
selon le selon l'adage les promesses les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient mais il y là constant il n'a pas
donné de détails sur ce que serait cette
nouvelle méthode il avait quand même
le calcul de démocratie participative
oui je sais pas si emmanuel macron je
pense qu'on peut pas lui faire le
reproche de ne pas saisir que
effectivement ce moment de la démocratie
électorale est arrivé je sais pas si on
doit dire à l'arrivée à la fin d'un
cycle mais il ya quand même un
essoufflement aujourd'hui extrêmement
fort
du côté de l'ensemble des citoyens est
d'ailleurs pas seulement je pense que
c'est une horde analyse de considérer
que ce sont simplement les les citoyens
en âge de voter je crois qu'il faudrait
raisonner aussi sur les primo votants et
les jeunes de 15 à 18 ans dans ce moment
avant leur premier vol donc est ce qu'il
y aura de nouvelles procédures
démocratiques qui vont rythmer ces cinq
prochaines années ou est-ce que emmanuel
macron comme il l'avait dit c'est à dire
un adepte en quelque sorte delà de la
responsabilité politique ce terme de
responsabilité quillan qui l'engagent
très souvent en disant viendra le temps
du bilan et vous saisirez les
instruments de la démocratie électorale
le vote pour évaluer positivement ou
négativement me sanctionnant je crois
que ce moment là c'est ce n'est plus
aujourd'hui entendues dans dans le pays
et les élections intermédiaires ne joue
plus son rôle réellement il ya une
demande de politique nationale très très
fort et vraiment les citoyens ou bien
séparés ce qui est relevé du chant local
et du chant national l'attend vis-à-vis
du chant national c est ce qu emmanuel
macron va démultiplier les
expérimentations à à l'instar de celle
de effectivement la convention citoyenne
pour le climat et il suffit pas
simplement de mettre en place de telles
procédures ce qui compte c'est à la fois
sur quelle thématique quelles
thématiques et pour moi c'est quand même
le sujet et deuxièmement qu'est ce que
l'on fait de ces procédures du bilan qui
est tirée est ce que vous on peut on
peut trouver beaucoup de vertus dans la
convention citoyenne pour le climat mais
150 propositions
c'est pour moi c'est impossible ensuite
de mettre ça dans l'arène parlementaire
et dire voilà alors me sont conférés
augmentation n'avait pas l'habitude de
ces conventions
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que d'une
certaine manière on a quasiment
délégitimer la procédure avec ce
résultat est donc il va falloir en
inventer une nouvelle je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait du discours des
macros où il parle de de bienveillance
et on va rester sur cette thématique
dinde à nouveau une nouvelle forme de
gouvernance à inventer collectivement
invention collective d'une méthode
refonder la bienveillance d'abord et
avec ambition et bienveillance pour
notre pays pour nous tout ce
que je veux pouvoir à vos côtés
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
cette ère nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refonder pour cinq années de
mieux au service de notre pays de notre
jeunesse chacun d'entre nous aura à s'y
engager car chacun d'entre nous compte
plus que lui même
c'est ce qui fait
du peuple français
cette force singulière
que j'aime si profondément si
intensément et que je suis si fier de
servir à nouveau
cette méthode refonder benjamin morel on
revient un peu à l'essence même de la
vème république avec peut-être plus de
référendum dans les cinq ans qui
viennent oui c'est à voir c'est à dire
qu'on a vu que beaucoup de proposition
de référendum ont jailli sous ce
quinquennat et qu'au bout du compte et
bien
ils n'ont pas tout à fait aboutie
notamment parce que eh bien quand on en
voyait quelque chose une forme de ballon
d'essai oms avec le sénat allait dire
non souvenez-vous notamment de la
révision consuel relative à
l'introduction du climat dans l'article
1er il était évident que le scénario
poserait d'entrée est donc lancé l'idée
de référendum est entre 10 et est entre
guillemets relativement facile donc il
faut faire attention malgré tout le
temps qu'un référendum même s'il n'est
pas que plébiscitaire souvenez-vous du
référendum de 2005 en 2005 jacques
chirac et à 45% popularité au mois de
novembre il est également à 45%
popularité au mois de mars le oui est
passé de 65 à ce à 45 % dans les
intentions de vote donc un référendum ce
n'est pas qu'un plébiscite mais un
président qui a subi un référendum
négatif est un président qui est quelque
peu estropiés donc c'est toujours
extrêmement compliqué sur la refondation
de la méthode là aussi il faut pas non
plus être tout à fait dupe pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que il ya en effet
une demande d'une partie de l'opinion
mais les réformes institutionnelles
intéresse relativement peu je me
souviens notamment d'une enquête au
moment de la crise des jeux les jeunes
ont sondé on était en plein débat sur le
rich ou l'ifop sondés et priorités des
français les réformes institutionnelles
était dernière à 6% le deuxième élément
est bien c'est peut-être le moment de le
faire parce qu'une peut-être peut-être
cependant ce bien tête mais sa soeur et
le 12e et le deuxième élément c'est que
pour réformer les institutions encore
une fois vous avez besoin de l'aval du
sénat or aujourd'hui on sait que sur les
grandes réformes institutionnelles et de
vraies tensions géo vers la vérité parce
qu'il est au côté d'alain gavand au
champ de mars le ministre de l'éducation
nationale elsa
oui on a senti un soulagement dans la
majorité vous avez vraiment eu peur elle
vous a fait peur cette élection je pense
que c'est très important c'est de
considérer qu'une élection n'est jamais
gagnée et bien sûr que celle ci n'était
pas gagné d'avancé
donc c'est vrai que ce soir on est
comptant non seulement de la victoire
mais de l'écart et voilà donc c'est pas
un soulagement mais c'est le fait que
jusqu'au bout il faut jouer le jeu
électoral le jeu de la démocratie et
c'est déjà la première leçon ce soir
emmanuel macron a également eu un mot
pour ceux qu'ils n'avaient pas voté pour
lui est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya eu
le programme mais que maintenant il va
falloir aussi composer avec le reste des
français bien sûr il est normal que le
président salue tous les français il est
le président de tous les français
renouveler aujourd'hui pour cinq ans
c'est la première fois qu'une telle
chose arrive le renouvellement d'un
président hors cohabitation et nivea un
programme qui est clair et qui bien
entendu a vocation à s'accomplir ça
n'interdit pas des choses
supplémentaires grâce à la discussion
avec toutes les parties prenantes on
peut espérer une france plus apaisé dans
les cinq ans qui viennent une france où
il ya moins de radicalité où la
politique change les choses concrètement
dans la vie des gens ça a été le cas sur
certains sujets au cours des cinq
dernières années qui viennent de passer
par exemple dans le domaine de
l'éducation mais il faut je l'espère
dans un contexte moins difficile réussir
à avancer sur les sujets qui compte pour
les français il a évidemment beaucoup
insisté sur l'écologie en particulier
justement sur l'école les enseignants
ils nous ont beaucoup suivi cette
campagne ils n'ont pas forcément
toujours tout compris est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce soir est-ce qu'ils
vont être revalorisées et ce qu'ils vont
avoir des missions nouvelles
emmanuel macron a dit qu'il allait
ouvrir un grand chantier sur l'école et
finalement on voit beaucoup de questions
sont ouverts pas forcément les réponses
c'est normal que les questions sont
ouvertes et qui a justement une grande
concertation commence dès cette année
dès 2022 d'abord pour poursuivre les
augmentations qui ont commencé qui ont
commencé d'abord pour les plus jeunes
les bulletins de salaire des professeurs
les plus jeunes a substantiellement
changé depuis deux ans en particulier
ses 165 euros net de plus par mois pour
les plus jeunes on est allé aussi vers
les milieux de carrière il va falloir
maintenant toucher tout le monde mais le
faire aussi sur la base de redéfinition
de dans le sens de l'intérêt général
dont le sens de l'intérêt du bien-être
aussi de tous les professeurs ce qui in
fine et aboutira aussi au bien-être de
tous les élèves donc ces sept ans ce
grand enjeu d'une école qui peut
franchir une nouvelle étape dans la vie
que de la république qui est ouvert
grâce à
qu'a dit le président dernière question
le président est réélu est ce que vous
ministre de l'éducation vous êtes
candidat à votre propre succession non
je suis candidat à rien par définition
aujourd'hui commence une nouvelle étape
le président vient de recevoir un mandat
des français celui qui va maintenant
composer le gouvernement avec le premier
ministre lula où la première ministre
qu'il choisira et ce sera bien ainsi
même si beaucoup jean michel maghe
blanquet ministre de l'éducation et
merci l amont d'un gamin qui est avec
steven martens sur place et je cite
aussi les équipes sandra cerqueira et
cécile siksou qui était au champ de mars
il avait aussi marion vigreux et louis
siby
erwan lecoeur on va terminer là dessus
nous reste un peu moins de cinq minutes
sur la question des hommes et des femmes
c'est intéressant qui pourrait être
premier ministre il ya une obligation de
renouvellement de toutes façons de la
part des manuels macron évidemment le
prémice mais même pour
la plupart des pauses son gouvernement
comment vous l'analysez c'est tout le
problème des manuels macron il va devoir
est renouvelée et montrer qu'il ya une
continuité il a un camp comme vous le
savez il n'a pas de parti politique ou
quasiment il n'a pas non plus de
beaucoup d'élus sur le terrain quasiment
pas ça va d'ailleurs être un problème
pour les législatives sa seule équipe
c'est son gouvernement s'il enlève les
gens du gouvernement il va falloir qu'il
retrouve d'autres personnes pour faire
équipe autour de lui donc c'est un peu
la problématique dans laquelle il est le
deuxième point c'est que on l'évoquait
pour les législatives emmanuel macron
est le seul qui a entre guillemets
une dynamique positive puisqu'il vient
d'être réélu il a un camp dans lequel il
n'est pas contesté pas contestable y a
pas de partie il ya quelques tous petits
tout petite échoppe à huit formations
différentes à lui avec petites
formations mais petit franc brossé déjà
quasiment négocier à peu près en plus je
rappelle législatives c'est quand même
le nerf de la guerre c'est là où on va
chercher l'argent pour survivre sur tous
les partis de france est donc quelque
part il a ses avantages là et je le
disais il a deux mois un mois et demi
devant lui où il va donner le tempo avec
les ministres le premier ministre ou la
première ministre un premier ministre
une première ministre un peu écolo ça
pourrait éventuellement aller chercher
d'un côté ou d'un autre en face il a des
forces politiques qui vont pilonner très
fortement sur le thème qu'on a évoqué
d'une cohabitation renouveler réinventer
à savoir une cohabitation dans laquelle
il y aurait 100 150 députés qui
pourraient opposé régulièrement ou
proposer éventuellement régulièrement et
emmanuel macron un gouvernement
d'ouverture assez élargi pour vous pour
versus justement à ces oppositions
frontales qu'on a un très concrètement
sociologiquement si j'étais emmanuel
macron il a le bloc central il a le bloc
libéral social libéral pour lui dire
rapidement de moins en moins social de
plus en plus libéral est allé chercher
peut-être yannick jadot des des gens qui
sont allés chercher des gens qui à
l'insu renoncer qu'à redorer un peu
comme nicolas hulot mais en plus sérieux
parce que nicolas hulot n'a pas fait
montre d'un grand sérieux politique
quelqu'un qui sera un peu plus politique
dans le domaine en effet l'écologie pour
faire des choses et donner des signaux
très rapidement parce que comme ça a été
dit au moment des législatives
l'écologie va redevenir comme aux
municipales comme régionales le sujet
principal événement sera une grande
nation à écologique est toujours très
coté vous l'avez vous même entendu et on
l'a bien compris pour l'instant l'accord
entre marine le pen et monsieur zemmour
n'est pas du tout fait pas du tout et en
plus comme ils ont de sociologie
complètement différente il n'est pas du
tout certain qu est-ce que cet accord se
fasse et donc là aussi l air pourrait
tirer son épingle du jeu ce camp là
n'est pas coalisés le camp de la gauche
et l'écologie n'est pas coalisés pour
législatives seul le corps macron
pourrait l'être en s'élargissant
notamment benjamin moore et je prends
vraiment très prudent puisqu'il ya deux
incertitudes d'abord il ya deux mois et
les deux mois peuvent permettre des
négociations locales c'est très longue
de moi pour le coup et le deuxième
élément si on ne sait pas qui va voter
pour les législatives il ya trois
scénarios soit une mobilisation
importante sur des thèmes on sera
content sait pas encore lesquels mai en
pleine crise du pouvoir d'achat et
cetera c'est possible soit des élections
où il ya une très très forte abstention
et où c'est le noyau dur des votants qui
votent oslo les csp + les personnes
âgées les territoires ruraux c'est pas
du tout la même campagne
si vous avez ce noyau dur ou si vous
avez une campagne très politique pour
l'instant nul ne peut le dire en 30
secondes marcel vous qu est ce qu une
élection et cette île tickets se joue là
avec un ancrage local aussi qui est
important ce sont les républicains qui
sont assez ancré localement est ce que
ça peu ils peuvent tirer leur épingle du
jeu quand même
savait très compliqué parce que on se
remet pas quand même d'un score d'une
chef de file à -2 5% et on repart en
campagne en indiquant que finalement
ouvert
n'est on va poursuivre les engagements
d'une candidate défaite sur le
gouvernement moi je rajouterais un point
dans l'analyse il faut il faut pas
écarter finalement pour aimer le
maquereau le choix d'un gouvernement et
d'un chef de gouvernement premier
ministre qui sera celui qui va mener la
campagne législative et qu'on risque
d'avoir de temps au regard du score aux
législatives si on est dans la
perspective d'une cohabitation je pense
que le risque est très faible et ça veut
dire un autre changement de gouvernement
au mois de juin et que là pour les huit
prochaines semaines ça va être un
gouvernement en fait commando est en
fait pour les fnatic va pas démarrer les
réformes là dans les prochains jours là
c'est le l'objectif c'est d'avoir une
majorité au parlement donc on peut
imaginer un gouvernement de combat très
politiques et beaucoup moins technique
ou expert sur les points forts du
programme à d'experts mais d'expérience
peut-être alors ou pas ou pas parce que
je crois qu'il ya un besoin de
renouvellement effectivement ça a été
rappelé ce n'est pas au sein du camp la
république en marche que les membres
imminents ont fait leurs preuves lors
des élections très vite claire
sauvegarder mon signe à l'endroit de
l'air puisque effectivement il ya
quelque chose qui se joue aussi pour
emmanuel macron dans cette fraction l'a
donc essayé d'envoyer des signaux pour
avoir effectivement une portion de
salaire qui pourrait passer l'alliance
avancé pour à sa merci beaucoup merci à
les quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
voilà c'est la fin de notre soirée
électorale je voulais remercier toutes
les équipes des chaînes parlementaires
public sénat et lcp assemblée nationale
évidemment merci à tous reporter qui
étaient sur place ce soir elsa monde un
gamin qui était au champ de mars avec
les équipes des manuels macro est en
train de nuit qui était dans le bois de
boulogne avec lé soutien de marine le
pen et puis on va citer tous ceux qui
nous accompagnent en tout cas
quelques-uns on oublie toujours du monde
albert ripamonti perrine tarneaud des
films goudard isabelle pain c'est
philippe de sonia la réalisation les
équipes de programmation également hôte
fauvel lucie span l'air et toutes les
rédactions dès le cp et 2 public sénat
on va se quitter avec ses grandes
déclarations vous avez entendu ce soir
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
et rester bien évidemment sur les
chaînes parlementaires six bogeys top
c'était un bonheur salut